[Musique]
Pierre Routurou, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit dans le cadre de votre nouveau
projet qui s'appelle le pacte finance
climat. Pourquoi avoir créé cette chose
là avec Jean-Josel ? avec Jean-Josel et
beaucoup de gens qui en ont marre des
discours creux sur les questions de
climat et qui pensent qu'il est urgent
qu'on passe à l'action parce que dans
quelques années sinon ce sera trop tard,
le dérèglement climatique va
s'accélérer, la perte de biodiversité va
devenir euh dramatique ou on va dépasser
un seuil, il sera trop tard pour agir.
Donc on veut que dans les mois qui
viennent, l'Europe, on sait très bien
qu'avec Donald Trump, rien ne va bouger
au niveau international. Donc on veut
que l'Europe arrête les discours et
passe à l'action. L'Europe et l'Afrique
doivent financer la transition
énergétique et on montre que c'est
possible, qu'il y a des de une somme
d'argent colossal qui peut être investi
dans la transition et que ça peut
devenir une bonne nouvelle au lieu
d'être un problème, ça peut devenir une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'on va créer
massivement des emplois.
Quel est le constat à l'heure actuelle
sur par exemple la perte de
biodiversité, sur la production de CO2,
sur l'augmentation
calorifique des océans, sur
l'acidification des océans, sur tout un
tas de de choses dans tous les domaines,
tous les clignotants sont au rouge comme
on dit gentiment. Euh vous avez
peut-être vu il y a quelques temps, il y
a 6 mois à la une du monde 15000
scientifiques qui disent "Il sera
bientôt trop tard." Et moi je vois des
scientifiques qui me disent qu'il
n'arrivent plus à dormir, que déjà ce
qu'ils écrivent c'est pour rester dans
le consensus de ce qui est totalement
certain sur les 30 dernières années,
mais que quand ils réfléchissent entre
eux sur vers quoi on va dans les 10, 20
ou 30 ans, ça les empêche de dormir pour
de vrai. Et moi, c'est maintenant de
plus en plus souvent que je me réveille
vraiment la nuit. Sur la question de la
biodiversité. Moi, j'ai créé le club
apiculture dans mon école quand j'étais
étudiant. Euh et on voit que
l'affaissement des populations
d'abeilles est monstrueux. Mais l'autre
jour, je voyais Gill Buff du muséum
d'histoire naturelle. Il me disait "Mais
écoute, c'est tout simple, quand tu
étais petit, souviens-toi quand tu
partais en vacances, c'était le rôle des
enfants de nettoyer le pare-brise parce
que moi j'habite, voilà, on traversait
la France pour aller dans les Pyréné et
Gill Bu faisait pareil avec ses ses
parents et il fallait nettoyer le
pare-brise parce qu'il y avait des
dizaines et des dizaines d'insectes qui
s'étaient percutés et maintenant on peut
faire 4 km 400 km sans avoir aucun
insecte." C'est une preuve parmi
d'autres que la biodiversité est en
train de s'effond de s'effondrer et
c'est pas une fatalité, c'est pas
météorite qui est arrivé comme pour la
fin des dinosaures. Quand les dinosaures
s'effondrent, c'était pas leur faute,
c'est un météorite qui arrive. Là, le
météorite, c'est nous, c'est nos modes
de vie, c'est notre façon de de
produire, de consommer qui produit un
effondrement de la biodiversité et un
dérèglement climatique de plus en plus
grave. Donc, c'est dramatique mais c'est
une bonne nouvelle. Ça veut dire que si
c'est nous qui sommes la cause du
problème, ça veut dire aussi qu'on peut
s'attaquer aux racines du problème. Si
c'est nous,
non, mais ça veut dire si c'est pas un
météorite, voilà, les dinosaures, ils y
peuvent rien. Il y a un météorite qui
arrive, il y a des volcans qui crachent,
il y a plus de lumière, la végétation
s'effondre. Voilà. Donc c'était foutu
foutu. Tà que nous ça n'est pas foutu.
80 plus de 95 % du réchauffement
climatique vient de l'activité humaine.
Donc ça veut dire que si on s'attaque
pour de vrai au problèmes de transport,
si on change si on isole tous les
bâtiments, si on change notre façon de
s'alimenter, si on change de modèle
agricole, ça fait un gros chantier mais
on peut en quelques années faire
s'effondrer nos productions de gaz à
effet de serre et donc on peut calmer le
jeu, on peut arrêter le dérèglement
climatique. Bon, avant de de commencer à
faire saigner les oreilles de nos
auditeurs, qui êtes-vous ? Qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait ? Et est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Ben, je m'appelle Pierre Larouturau,
comme on bien, je suis euh né à
Périgueux dans le sud de la France. Euh,
j'ai 54 ans, je suis ingénieur agronome
de formation. Donc, c'est question,
j'étais un élève de René Dumont,
peut-être que ça dit rien à ceux qui
nous regardent, mais c'était le premier
candidat écolo en 74, je crois. Et donc
quand j'étais étudiant, j'allais chez
lui me raconter tout ce qu'il avait fait
en Afrique par mon par éparvau. Et déjà
il expliqué qu'on était sur une petite
planète magnifique mais très fragile et
que déjà il expliqué que si on
continuait à vouloir consommer plus,
avoir plus de voitures, avoir plus de de
consommation d'énergie déjà il y a 30
ans René Dumond disait "C'est de la
folie, ça ne tient pas la route, on est
sur une planète finie et on peut pas
avoir une croissance indéfinie." Et il
avait tout à fait raison. 95 % de ce que
Zené Dumont il y a 30 ans est en train
de se vérifier. Donc j'ai fait l'AGRO
puis j'ai fait Sciences Po puis j'ai été
pendant 11 ans consultant dans une
entreprise de de conseil en stratégie en
conduite du changement. Puis j'étais
licencié à cause de mes idées en matière
sociale par c'est moi qui lancé le débat
sur la semaine de 4 jours pour réduire
le le chômage, réduire le temps de
travail pour réduire le chômage. Mais il
y a quand même 400 entreprises qui ont
mis en place mes idées qui ont créé des
centaines d'emplois. Donc c'était je
continue à penser que c'était une bonne
idée et puis là je suis engagé avec
Jean-Josel comme vous l'avez dit avec
plein d'autres gens des 150 VIP je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais
avant ça vous avez fait un petit passage
au Parti socialiste
j'ai été au Parti socialiste.
C'est venu reparti aller chez
voilà avec Stéphanel on a été au PS on a
quitté euh on est allé ensemble à Europe
écologie parce qu'on a cru un moment
qu'Europe écologie allait renouveler
l'offre politique avec un vrai message.
Donc on a vous levez les yeux au ciel
mais on y a cru. Et donc avec Stéphan
Essel et quelques autres, on a quitté le
PS pour aller à Europe écologie et puis
on a compris au bout de 2 ou 3 ans que
non ce n'était pas Europe écologie.
Voilà pour plein de raisons. On a
dénoncé quelques agissements
pas très éthiques. Devant il y avait
Vajoli et puis derrière il y en a qui
magouillent comme des cochons. Donc ça
nous on a dénoncé ça. Donc on s'est pas
fait que des amis. On est revenu au PS
toujours avec Stéphan Essel il y a 6 ans
quand le PS est devenu hégémonique avait
tous les leviers. On a essayé de de
changer la politique de François Holland
de Jean Marquero. On a fait une motion.
On a fait le club le collectif Roosevelt
2012 et puis on a vu que le PS était
incapable de bouger. Puis on a vu que il
amenait le pays dans le mur. Enfin que
il ne qu'on ne réglait aucun des
problèmes du pays. Euh et on a essayé de
créer avec quelques amis une nouvelle
donne. Mais la vie politique est
compliquée. Je ne pensais pas qu'il
pouvait avoir autant de violence, autant
de Moi, je suis un peu naïf. Je suis
plutôt un humaniste. Je ne vois pas je
le but de ma vie n'est pas le pouvoir.
Mon but est vraiment de transformer les
choses avant que ça s'effondre. Mais
héros, c'est plutôt Gandy, Nelson
Mandela, des gens comme ça. C'est pas
SarkoZi ou Chirac.
Martin Luther King peut-être. Non.
Oui, Martin Luther King vraiment. C'est
l'autre jour. Ben vous avez récemment
rencontré John Palé et j'avais envoyé
des messages à John et à Ch pour dire il
y a un super film sur Martin Luther
King. Voilà un gars qui a fait bouger la
qui a fait bouger la société qui a pris
des risques et qui parlait à
l'intelligence et à la conscience des
gens. Donc c'est plutôt ça nos modèles.
Et là je suis engagé sur un seul sujet
parce que c'est très compliqué de faire
bouger les choses. Il y a on est des
dans un pays où il y a beaucoup
d'inertie vous payz.
On a créé une association donc je suis
depuis jusqu'à maintenant j'étais
bénévole. Je vivais ma femme et prof
donc ça la stabilité de j'ai deux
enfants. Je suis marié j'ai deux enfants
et c'est ma femme qui est professeur
donc qui assurait la stabilité de de la
famille et puis moi je mes bouquins se
vendent pas mal. Et puis donc vous
gagnez
là, je suis à 2300 net par mois. Donc je
suis délégué, on a créé une association
avec Jean-Josel et je suis délégué
général depuis le mois de janvier, c'est
nouveau. Sinon avant j'étais bénévole.
Euh et qu'est-ce que donc on a créé
cette association pour rassembler sur un
seul objectif, provoquer un sursaut sur
les questions de climat et de
biodiversité et obtenir un traité
européen qui finance la transition.
Donc, j'oublie pendant quelques mois les
autres sujets. En tout cas, quand je
suis en France, je ne parle plus des
questions de temps de travail ou des et
je me concentre avec d'autres pour
obtenir un traité européen. Euh parce
qu'en plus beaucoup de gens comprennent
que l'Europe peut mourir sielle est pas
capable de changer et qu'encore la
semaine dernière, Angela Merkel et
Emmanuel Macron ont dit que c'était
cette année, c'est en décembre, le 13 et
le 14 décembre qu'on doit décider où va
l'Europe, est-ce qu'il y a ou pas des
nouveaux traités. Et donc je mets euh
toute mon énergie pour obtenir un traité
européen qui va financer la transition
euh en Europe autour de la Méditerranée
et en Afrique.
Votre association regroupe combien de
personnes ?
Très peu parce que le but n'est pas de
Je crois qu'il y a quatre adhérents. Le
but n'est pas du tout on a des milliers
de gens qui se mobilisent. Hier, j'étais
à Renn, il y avait plusieurs centaines
de personnes dans la salle mais en tant
que tel l'association c'est juste quatre
personnes. C'est qui qui cher ça du
point de vue administratif. C'est
Jean-Josel qui est le président, c'est
trois amis qui s'occupent de de la
logistique et puis c'est tout. On est
juste tourner vers l'action. Notre
objectif et à durée limitée. On veut
cette année obtenir un traité européen.
C'est des dons. Vous vivez avec des dons
?
On vit avec des dons. Souvent les gens
qui signent, il y a un site climat-2020.
Climat-2020.
Et les gens souvent qui signent font des
dons.
Donc je peux vous dire qu'on est on
roule pas sur l'or. Le mois dernier, on
a été payé en retard. On n pas payé le
loyer ce mois-ci. Donc tout ça c'est de
même vous, je sais pas comment vous
financez ici mais nous on est une toute
petite équipe. Voilà,
on va rencontrer la semaine prochaine
les gens de KissKiss Bang pour lancer un
crowfunding et puis il y a des gens qui
nous aident quand on a quand c'est trop
dur. Il y a des copains qui font un don.
On est une association d'intérêt
général, donc il y a la déduction
fiscale. Donc c'est pas glorieux mais ça
nous a ça nous permet voilà de et puis
partout où on va hier j'étais invité à
Renn, c'est l'université de Rennes,
c'est la maison de l'Europe, c'est Ouest
France qui nous invite. Je suis logé
chez des chez des militants. Voilà,
c'est la frugalité, c'est aussi là, je
suis content encore depuis 4 mois, j'ai
un salaire, ce qui est je me plains pas
mais surtout je me plains pas parce
qu'on voit qu'on peut peut-être faire
bouger les choses.
C'est pas un peu David contre Goliath ?
Ben c'est ce qu'on disait.
Je j'étais un grand ami de Stéphan
Essel. J'ai eu la chance d'être un grand
grand ami de Stéphan Essel. Et Stéphan
Essel encore très peu de temps, quelques
jours avant de mourir, je le revois chez
lui et il disait qu'il fallait lutter
contre le découragement. Et alors
Stéphane savait qu'il pouvait y restait
bientôt. On a fait le on a parlé de sa
vie, on a parlé de la mort qui venait et
puis il me dit "Mon Pierre, qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour lutter contre le
découragement ?" Il me dit "Je serais
fier de faire un petit livre avec toi."
Je dis "Attends Stéphane, n'inversons
pas. C'est moi qui sera fier de faire un
petit livre avec toi." Mais donc ce
monsieur qui avait plus de 90 ans qui
savait qu'il pouvait mourir, se demander
comment lutter contre le découragement.
Il faut rappeler aux gens que on pense
que les trucs sont foutus, qu'on y
arrivera pas. Mais on a connu
l'apartide. Il disait toujours, on a
connu l'apartide et la fin de
l'apartide. On a connu le mur de
Bernard. Oui. Non mais c'est vrai.
Pardon. Les sinon les gens si les gens
se découragent, ben moi je pense que
c'est peut-être quand on est très près
du précipice, quand des millions de gens
se disent ça sent mauvais, ça devient
très grave, c'est peut-être à ce
moment-là qu'on arrive à faire bouger
les choses. Là, je vois que je suis
invité dans des villes très différentes.
À la même semaine, je suis invité à
l'Orient, une ville de gauche, et à
Saint-Étienne, une ville de droite. Et à
chaque fois, les salles sont pleines et
dans les deux cas, le maire dit qu'il
veut nous soutenir et qui veut mettre
ses réseaux au service de notre projet.
On a des gens très différents, aussi
bien Laurence Pariso que les syndicats
européens. Laurence Pariso, elle
m'appelle en disant qu'elle n'est pas du
tout d'accord avec ce que je dis en
matière sociale. Elle commence par me
dire "Vous ne m'avez jamais convaincu en
matière sociale, mais sur la question du
climat, j'ai envie de vous aider." Je
dis "Ben OK, pendant 1 an, je ne parle
plus des questions sociales alors que ça
reste un sujet dramatique mais pendant 1
an, on essaie de rassembler tous ceux
qui veulent vraiment faire bouger les
choses sur le climat. Les gens
d'Alternativa, les gens de la fondation
Abéire, les gens de France Nature
Environnement, les gens des amis de la
terre. On rassemble tout. On parle
souvent du plafond de verre qui empêche
les femmes ou qui empêchent les noirs de
progresser dans les entreprises. Et si
on veut faire péter un plafond de verre,
il faut se concentrer sur un endroit. Si
on fait juste plein de petits coups
n'importe où, le plafond de verre, il
reste. Par contre, si on se concentre,
on peut peut-être faire casser le
plafond de verre et obtenir une
victoire. Et bien nous, on pense que la
question du climat aujourd'hui est assez
grave pour que les gens se mettent en
mouvement et qu'on rassemble des gens et
que du coup on obtienne une victoire au
niveau du un traité européen.
Vous vous avez rassemblé du côté des
entreprises, des grands patrons, des
grands groupes ? Est-ce que vous avez
été démarchés pour avoir des dons ?
On commence juste pour avoir des
signatures. Pour le moment, notre
objectif n'est pas encore d'avoir des
dons. Objectif est d'avoir des gens qui
signent. Donc je veux dire, on a eu
Laurence Pariso, ancienne patronne du
MDEF. On a le patron des phaes, vous
savez le viaduc de Mo, c'est quand même
une des plus grandes entreprises. Le
patron des phaes a dit qu'il signait. On
espère bientôt avoir d'autres chefs
d'entreprise. Il y a des patrons de PME
qui signent. On est on ça fait juste 6
mois qu'on existe mais on est en train
de de rencontrer des chefs d'entreprise.
Le CJD le centre des jeunes dirigeants
regroupe 4000 chefs d'entreprise qui
essayent tant bien que mal de tenir en
même temps l'efficacité et la justice
sociale, une innovation sociale et
certains d'entre eux ont demandé que le
CJD se prononce sur notre projet au mois
de septembre. Et puis il y a des
associations d'élus qui se qui sont avec
nous.
Quel pouvoir public ?
On a on a des députés il y a 10 jours.
Il y a 2 semaines, on a été auditionné à
l'Assemblée nationale avec Jean-Josel,
climatologue prix Nobel de la un des qui
était vice-président du JC quand le JC a
reçu le prix Nobel de la paix. On a été
auditionné par deux commissions de
l'Assemblée, la Commission affaires
européenne et la Commission
développement durable. Et on arrive là à
50 députés qui nous soutiennent de tous
horizons à part des les très proches de
VOER qui n'étaient visiblement pas
d'accord. Mais sinon, ça va de la France
insoumise.
Tu es pas d'accord pourquoi ?
Euh en gros euh quand parce qu'on
explique qu'il faut euh qu'il faut
mettre une contribution sur les
bénéfices, que si on veut vraiment
prendre le taureau par les cornes, il y
a besoin d'argent. Si on veut faire la
guerre au dérèglement climatiques, si on
veut faire la guerre à l'effondrement de
la biodiversité, il faut des budgets et
c'est pas euh et donc
vous trompez pas de guerre.
Pourquoi ?
Ben vous faites la guerre au
réchauffement climatique. Mais pourquoi
vous faites pas la guerre aux
entreprises qui polluent ?
Je sais pas s'il faut faire la guerre
aux entreprises. Je pense qu'il faut
tous changer nos comportements que tous
on doit se demander voyons, est-ce que
je peux manger moins de viande ? Est-ce
que je peux me dire je ne prends plus
jamais l'avion ? Est-ce que je peux me
dire que je ne prends la voiture que
quand c'est vraiment indispensable et
que et que je pense qu'il faut changer
les règles du jeu, augmenter le prix du
carbone et qu'il faut donner des
financements par un des objectifs, c'est
que toutes les tous les bâtiments
publics et privés soient isolés en
France. Je sais pas où vous habitez.
Moi, j'habite dans un immeuble tout à
fait banal et on est comme tous les
autres immeubles, on dépense des
quantités d'énergie qui réchauffent la
planète. Mais et si je dois payer de ma
poche l'isolation, euh le syndique va
dire non parce que c'est 25000 € ou
30000 € par appartement. Et les gens
vont dire non. Par contre, s'il y a un
financement public, si on montre que
l'Europe peut nous peut financer en gros
la moitié avec ce qu'on propose, on
pourrait dire qu'on divise par de la
facture et que chez vous, comme chez
moi, on a une aide qui fait qu'on divise
par de la facture pour faire les travaux
d'isolation. Et ben peut-être que là on
pourra accélérer et que dans 20 ans tous
les bâtiments publics et privés seront
isolés et qu'on on aura les moyens de
gagner la bataille contre le déréglement
climatique. Et en même temps, on va
demander aux entreprises de se
transformer. Mais je pense pas qu'and je
pense pas qu'il faille chercher des
beaux émissaires et dire ce sont les
entreprises. Il y a des entreprises qui
font n'importe quoi.
Donc avant les entreprises, c'est
peut-être la façon de consommer. Est-ce
que est-ce que votre programme est-ce
que votre pacte engendre un effet de
plateau sur la croissance, un effet de
décroissance ?
Euh sur la question de la croissance,
fait partie des gens comme beaucoup qui
disent que cet indicateur ne veut plus
rien dire. C'est une c'est incroyable
qu'il prennent autant de place encore
dans le débat public que on pourrait me
compter le nombre de de fois où des
dirigeants politiques de droite et de
gauche disent qu'avec eux la croissance
va revenir. La croissance va revenir. Je
crois que ça ne signifie rien que c'est
déjà il y a 40 ans quand certains
disaient que quand s'il y a un
tremblement de terre et que tout
s'effondre et qu'il faut tout
reconstruire, c'est très bon pour la
croissance. Si les gens sont dépressifs
et ce bourdent de médicaments, c'est
très bon pour la croissance. Par contre,
si les gens sont juste cools, heureux
dans leur vie, passent des soirées
cooles avec les amis, ça n'est pas bon
pour la croissance alors que tout va
bien. Donc je pense que l'indicateur de
PIB ne veut rien dire. Mais en même
temps, la décroissance ne veut pas dire
grand-chose non plus. Il faudrait dire
qu'est-ce qui doit croître ? Le nombre
de gens qui sont bien dans leur dans
leur peau, qui ont un boulot correct,
qui ont une maison correcte, qui ne
perdent pas trop de temps dans les
transports. Ça ça doit doit croître. Et
ce qui doit décroître, c'est notre
empreinte carbone. Elle doit
s'effondrer. On doit arriver à zéro
émission dans les 30 ans. Ce qui doit
décroître, c'est notre consommation de
viande. C'est ce qui doit décroître
arriver à zéro, c'est la consommation
d'énergie fossile. Voilà. Et globalement
ce qu'on propose, quel sera l'impact sur
le PIB ? Je n'en sais rien et je m'en
fiche. Peut-être que au début, si on
veut isoler tous les bâtiments publics
et privés, peut-être que au début ça va
faire monter le PIB. Mais si après ça le
but est de ne plus du tout consommer
d'énergie carbonée, peut-être que le PIB
va diminuer. Et honnêtement, je m'en
fiche. Moi les indicateurs qui
m'intéressent c'est les émissions de
CO2, c'est la biodiversité, c'est le
nombre de chômeurs et de précaires, le
nombre de gens qui sont en situation de
pauvreté,
la démographie.
La démographie en France, dans En
France, je finis en France et dans les
pays du sud. On peut pas avoir seulement
des indicateurs sur la France et
l'Europe.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous anticipez ?
Est-ce que vous poussez à une
décroissance démographique ?
Une décroissance démographique, je pense
c'est très compliqué. Par contre, je
pense c'est un dialogue qu'on doit avoir
avec les sociétés civiles. C'est un
sujet qui est un peu tabou. Mais la
question de la démographie par en
Afrique est un sujet qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à aborder avec nos amis.
On commençons par l'Europe hein.
Je suis pas sûr qu'il fallait une
décroissance. Non, je je pense pas qu'il
fallait une décroissance de la
démographie. Par contre, on peut la
planète peut on peut très bien vivre
avec encore autant d'êtres humains mais
en supposant que on arrête de vouloir
manger de la viande tous les jours et de
vouloir avoir vous entendez par
retourner être humain. Est-ce qu'on part
sur une démographie sur une croissance
exponentielle ?
Non, justement. Non, mais pardon, je
je me fais l'avocat du diable hein.
Vous faites l'avocat du diable. Euh
voilà, entre une croissance
exponentielle et la décroissance,
peut-être qu'il y a une stabilisation,
peut-être qu'on peut
un effet de plateau. Donc
un effet de plateau, oui, si c'est ça
que vous voulez app un effet de plateau,
en tout cas avec 7 milliards d'êtres
humains, on arrive à vivre correctement.
C'est-à-dire que si encore une fois si
chacun ne veut pas avoir sa voiture
personnelle qui fait du bruit, qui
pollue qui est très puissante et manger
de la viande tous les jours et partir en
vacances en avion, voilà, ce mode de vie
là est insupportable à tout point de
vue. Mais si on vit de façon un peu plus
frugale, c'està-dire que si on on lutte
contre l'obsolescence programmée, si on
comprend qu'on a pas besoin d'un nouveau
costume, un nouveau pantalon tous les 6
mois, si on comprend que la plupart des
déplacements, on les fait à pied ou en
vélo et que et sinon en transport en
commun et que c'est exceptionnel qu'on
prenne une voiture et c'est pas
forcément sa voiture personnelle mais ça
peut être une voiture qu'on utilise
comme on utilise des vélibes qu'on en a
besoin, qu'on utilisera de temps en
temps des voitures qui consomment qui
seront plus petites, moins rapides et
beaucoup moins polluantes. Et ben si on
va vers ça en 10 15 ans pas en 3
semaines mais pas non plus dans 40 ans,
si on va vers ça la planète peut
permettre à c 8 milliards d'êtres
humains à 7 milliard
de vivre correctement. Donc pardon, là
où il y a un sujet qui aujourd'hui est
un tabou et qu'il faut mettre sur la
table vite, c'est avec les sociétés
civiles, avec les citoyens, son sont des
hommes et des femmes adultes comme nous
la question de la démographie en
Afrique. Parce que il faut tout faire
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et contre le dérèglement
climatique. Il faut tout faire pour
permettre aux gens qui vivent en Afrique
de lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique et de s'adapter. Mais les
prévisions, le scénario principal pour
le le JC ou la FAO, c'est qu'il y aura
de moins en moins d'eau que en Afrique.
Quand l'eau va tomber, ce sera de plus
en plus violent. L'autre jour, il y a eu
20 morts au Kenya. Ça fait des semaines
qu'ils attendaient de l'eau et quand
l'eau arrive, c'est tellement violent
qu'il y a 20 morts au au Kenya. Mais
globalement donc de moins en moins d'eau
et de plus en plus d'évaporation. Donc
le scénario principal, c'est que les
récoltes vont perdre entre - 40 et - 60
%. En gros, les récoltes vont être
divisées par deux en Afrique. Donc dans
sur la plus dans la plupart des régions
d'Afrique. Donc si les récoltes sont
divisées par deux et que la population
double, on voit bien qu'on va vers un
gros gros problème. Donc la question de
la démographie en particulier en
Afrique, ça ne peut pas rester un sujet
tabou. Il faut qu'on arrive à avoir un
nouveau partenariat pour de vrai entre
l'Afrique et l'Europe et qu'on mette
cette question sur la table. C'est pas à
nous de décider de même que vous je sais
pas combien vous avez d'enfants et c'est
vous qui décidez mais on peut pas cette
question ne peut pas rester tabou.
Au niveau des finances, au niveau de des
marchés financiers, est-ce que vous
comptez faire deux trois petites actions
? Est-ce que vous avez un plan d'attaque
?
C'est pas deux trois petites actions,
c'est que c'est le cœur de notre c'est
le cœur de notre sujet. On montre que si
on veut éviter une catastrophe
climatique, il y a besoin de d'une
transformation radicale qu'il faut
arrêter les rustines, qu'il faut arrêter
les discours, les COP 21, les COP 28,
les COP 20 49 bis et qu'il faut passer à
l'action. Surtout que avec Trump à la
Maison Blanche, on sait très bien que
les COPES, la prochaine COP sera un
échec. On sait très bien qu'il n'y aura
aucun accord international.
Mais Trump, si vous avez compris ce que
le train de vie des Américains est non
négociable.
Oui. Alors la bonne nouvelle, c'est
quand même
ce sont les mots de bouche.
Oui. Alors la bonne nouvelle, c'est
quand même que tout le monde n'est pas
comme ça. Vous savez que sur les 50
États américains, il y en a quand même,
je crois, 38 qui ont voté des textes
pour dire que eux voulaient rester dans
la logique des accords de Paris. Quand
il y a des feux de forêt, autrefois
quand on était petit, les feux de forêt
c'était au mois d'août. Maintenant quand
il y a des feux de forêt juste avant
Noël en Californie parce ça fait des
années qu'il y a une sécheresse
monstrueuse que les arbres crèvent et
qu' peuvent brûler n'importe comment et
que les pompiers c'est tellement violent
que les pompiers n'arrivent pas à
arrêter les incendies et qu'il y a
300000 Américains qui doivent quitter
leur maison juste avant Noël à cause des
incendies. Il ils se disent que Bush
devrait venir voir et que pour eux le
réchauffement climatique que Trump
pardon m'excusez que Trump euh devrait
venir voir et que pour eux c'est une
évidence que le réchauffement climatique
existe et qui est en train de
s'aggraver, qu'il a des conséquences
dramatiques. Donc heureusement Trump ne
représente pas tous les États-Unis. Il y
a 38 États sur 50 qui qui ont signé, qui
ont voté des textes pour dire "Nous, on
continue. Il y a des villes, il y a des
associations, il y a des citoyens qui
font bouger les choses."
Lesquels n'ont pas signé ? Je connais
pas la liste par cœur des 12 qui n'ont
pas signé mais je pourrais vous
l'envoyer la prochaine fois, je n'en
sais rien. Mais en tout cas, je sais que
fort heureusement Trump n'est n'a pas
tous les pouvoirs qu'il y a des choses
qu'on peut faire au niveau local comme
en France d'ailleurs. Mais par contre,
c'est vrai qu'un accord international
que pour que la COP 24 soit vraiment un
succès, il faudrait que Trump signe. Et
ça, on sait très bien que ça n'est pas
possible. Donc raison de plus pour que
les l'Europe mette les bouchées doubles
et que l'Europe dise nous on finance la
transition. Donc j'enviens à votre
question sur les marchés financiers.
Voilà. Donc voilà. Donc globalement le
problème financier, il est colossal.
L'autre jour en Allemagne à 3 mois c il
y a eu une grande journée, c'est
l'industrie allemande. C'est
intéressant. C'est l'industrie allemande
qui a fait travailler pendant 1 an et
qui a rendu un rapport de 300 pages pour
dire nous voulons réussir la transition
énergétique. Ça n'est pas une option
parmi d'autres, c'est une obligation
morale. Sinon nos sociétés vont
s'effondrer. Ça va être une souffrance
terrible. Donc première chose, c'est
plutôt bien de montrer que c'est pas
seulement Greenpeace ou les amis de la
terre qui disent ça, que petit à petit,
on a gagné quand même une partie de la
bataille des idées et que le cœur de
l'économie allemande, l'industrie
allemande a travaillé pendant 1 an et
dit "Nous voulons réussir la transition
mais ils expliquent à Merkel qu'il faut
50 milliards chaque année. Ils font ils
envoient un rapport de 300 pages à
Anguela Merkel plein de pistes pour
montrer que c'est possible qu'on il y a
encore besoin d'un effort de recherche
mais globalement on sait ce qu'il faut
faire mais disent à Merkel il nous faut
50 milliards chaque année rien que pour
réussir la transition dans l'industrie
et madame Merkel fait glops parce que 50
milliards elle ne sait pas comment les
trouver la semaine suivante c'est au
Pays-Bas que il y a un article à l'une
des journaux pour dire si on veut éviter
que l'océan monte parce que si l'océan
monte de 2 m ou de 2,50 c'est les 3/4 de
la population des Pays-Bas qui doivent
déménager. Donc chez eux, c'est un sujet
qui de national géographique
aujourd'hui,
je l'ai pas vu mais
qui dit que les tris/4 de l'humanité va
crever d'ici 2100 à cause de fortes
montées de chaleur.
Mais c'est aussi un vrai sujet. Oui.
Comment ça va se passer ? On va terminer
la partie financière. Je viendrai sur
Non mais oui, la réponse est oui. C'est
que si vous avez la canicule de 2003,
non mais la
la réponse est oui sur la gravité. Si
vous me branchez sur la la mocher sur
les trucs en Allemagne, l'industrie dit
on a besoin de 50 milliards. Euh en
France, nous on travaille avec la
fondation la Abépierre qui travaille sur
les problèmes de précarité énergétique.
Des millions de gens qui n'ont pas de
quoi se chauffer correctement pendant
l'hiver ou qui crèvent de chaud au
contraire pendant l'été parce qu'ils
sont mal isolés. Donc c'est un problème
d'abord de d'injustice sociale. C'est
les plus pauvres qui sont les plus
touchés aujourd'hui en Europe par le
dérèglement climatique. Et puis ce
serait bien s'il pouvaient vivre si tous
ces gens pouvaient vivre correctement.
vivre que leur ensemble de le de leur
appartement soit à une bonne température
pendant l'hiver comme en était et en
même temps ce serait bon pour la planète
s'ils avaient pas besoin de mettre le
chauffage à fond. Donc la fondation
Abéière avec d'autres, c'est le
collectif rénovant euh a un plan et
montre comment on pourrait créer
massivement des emplois et comment c'est
rentable d'ici 15 ans mais il faut
quelques milliards pour amorcer la
pompe. Et
vous demandez 1000 milliards, c'est ça ?
Donc nous c'est pas nousard
voilà c'est pas nous c'est la cour des
comptes européennes parce qu'il y en a
qui rigolent 1000 milliards le chiffre
est trop rond ça fait rigolo. Et ben non
c'est pas rigolo. C'est la cour des
comptes européennes qui dit que si on
regarde ce qu'il faut en Allemagne dans
l'industrie, ce qu'il faut au Pays-Bas
pour lutter contre le réchauffement et
pour faire monter des digues parce que
si le niveau de l'OC monte il y a des
grandes digues qu'il faut consolider et
rehausser. Si on regarde ce qu'il faut
au Portugal, voilà globalement la Cour
des comptes européennes dit que ce qu'on
fait est totalement insuffisant. Ils
disent que c'est monstrueux notre
inaction. Ils disent que c'est pas
foutu, qu'il n'est pas trop tard pour
agir. Bonne nouvelle, on peut encore, si
on se retrousse les manches, on peut
encore gagner la partie. Et ils disent,
il faut chaque année 1115 milliards. Le
chiffre de la Cour des comptes que je
trouve un peu trop précis parce qu'à 1
milliard près, honnêtement, on sait pas
trop mais ça donne un ordre de grandeur.
Il faut 1100 milliards. Donc comme vous
avez bossé votre sujet, vous avez
peut-être vu ce qu'on disait il y a 5
ans ou 6 ans avec Stéphan Essel, avec
Rocard, avec d'autres dans le collectif
Roosevelt. Pai à leur âme.
Pai à leur âme. Euh, on disait pour
sauver les banques, on a mis 1000
milliards. Il faudrait mettre 1000
milliards pour sauver le climat. Et
certains disaient "Ouais, vous avez
raison." Et puis d'autres disaient "Mais
c'est pas sérieux, ça n'est pas
possible. La banque centrale ne voudra
jamais. Les Allemands ne voudront pas."
Et puis il y a 3 ans, il y a un tabou
qui est tombé, je voulais apporter parce
qu'il y a des gens qui n'y croient pas.
La Banque centrale européenne annonce
qu'elle va créer 1000 milliards. Il y
avait eu deux trimestres où l'activité
retombait même en Allemagne. Donc tout
le monde flippé. Est-ce qu'on retourne
en récession ? Et la banque centrale dit
"Qu'est-ce que je peux faire ?" Et la
banque centrale annonce qu'elle va créer
1000 milliards. Autrefois, on disait
qu'on faisait tourner la planche
habillée parce qu'autre fois, c'était
vraiment des planches en métalour le
cas.
Et maintenant, c'est des ordinateurs.
Mario Dragui dit à quelqu'un de son
équipe, "Tu me tu crées 80 milliards et
avec trois ordinateurs, on donne aux
banques 80 milliards tous les mois."
Donc c'est on met un mot compliqué pour
que les gens se disent "Oh là là, je
comprends pas donc il vaut mieux pas que
je me mêle sinon je vais dire des
bêtises." Donc la plupart des citoyens
ne le savent pas ou ont peur de s'en
mêler de peur de dire des bêtises. Mais
donc ça on appelle ça le quantitative
easing. Mais en fait c'est très simple.
La banque centrale a le droit de créer
de la monnaie à partir de rien. Elle
annonce qu'elle crée 1000 milliards. Ça
c'est le quantitative easing de routine.
Elle a créé elle je vous mets une
parenthèse
depuis le début de la crise financière,
elle a créé combien d'argent à partir de
rien ? La Banque centrale européenne ?
2008, il y avait eu tout d'un coup 1000
milliards pour sauver les banques.
Heureusement parce que sinon le système
s'effondré. Aux États-Unis, il y avait
eu deux fois 1000 milliards et
d'ailleurs vous pouvez retrouver un
article qu'on a fait là aussi avec
Michel Rocard qui montrait que c'était
quand même surréaliste le manque de
démocratie, le manque de contrôle
démocratique parce que aux États-Unis,
ces deux journalistes qui avaient
peut-être eu des fuites ou qui avaient
eu le nez creux et qui ont gagné un
procès contre la banque centrale
américaine, contre la réserve fédérale
en disant "Nous ponçons, les
journalistes disaient devant le juge, on
pense que la banque centrale en a fait
beaucoup plus que ce qu'elle dit. On
aimerait regarder ce qu'elle a fait." Et
donc c'est un juge qui au nom de la
Constitution américaine a donné le droit
à deux journalistes de déplucher, de
rentrer dans vraiment dans la
comptabilité de la banque centrale
américaine. Et ils ont découvert que la
banque centrale avait créé 1200
milliards. 1200 milliards de plus que ce
qu'elle avait dit pour aider les
banques. Voilà. Donc ça pose quand même
un vrai problème de contrôle
démocratique quand on se rend compte que
dans toutes nos villes, les conseillers
municipaux s'arrachent les cheveux pour
trouver euh 300000 € au niveau de de
notre pays comme en Allemagne ou comme
en Espagne, les députés prennent 3 mois
pour voter un budget et s'ils peuvent
déplacer 2 milliards, c'est le maximum.
Et là, on découvre que les banques
centrales sans aucun contrôle
démocratique créent des milliers de
milliards. Je reviens à ce que votre
question depuis 2008 totalité,
il y a eu pour dans l'urgence en 2008,
il y a eu 1000 milliards que les banques
ont remboursé petit à petit et puis ce
qui nous intéresse depuis 3 ans, il y a
eu 6000 milliards et puis ce qu'on
appelle des TLTRO par exemple au mois de
mars dernier il y a 1 an 230 milliards
en une journée.
Voilà 3 milliards à ta négatif. Donc on
peut montrer et personne ne l'a
critiqué. On a fait un livre avec
Jean-Josel et puis les gens de top
niveau nous ont aidé même s'ils
n'apparaissent pas pour qu'on ne dise
pas de bêtises et personne ne nous a
reproché la moindre erreur de calcul
depuis qu'on a sorti notre initiative.
On peut montrer que la banque centrale a
créé 2500 milliards. La banque centrale
européenne en 2 ans et demi vient de
créer 2500 milliards. Donc
depuis 2008 ça fait combien
au total ? Ça fait presque 4000
milliards à 2000 3500.
Là il est en train de continuer de
diminuer.
Voulez un petit peu d'eau. Non
ou je vais prendre un petit peu d'eau.
Vous êtes trop bon. Merci. Euh en gros
c'est euh 3800 milliards. On peut
montrer que au total dans les mesures
d'urgence et dans ce qui a été fait les
mesures de routine depuis 3 ans, il y a
eu 3800 milliards.
Ça a été réinjecté dans l'économie euh
réelle ou ils sont obligés de faire des
taux négatifs ?
Très très bonne question. C'est le un
des sujets fondamentaux. On montre aussi
de façon très concrète si vous allez sur
notre site, vous voyez les courbes, vous
voyez les chiffres, tout ça est
documenté qu'il y a 11 % de cet argent,
11 % qui est allé dans l'économie
réelle. les prêts au PME, les prêts au
ménage, les prêts aux collectivités ont
repris un peu, c'est 11 %. L'essentiel
89 % presque 90 % comme on dit à
Bruxelles est parti à la spéculation. Et
tous les mois maintenant le FMI nous dit
attention vous jouez avec le feu, on
risque une récession, on risque une
crise financière plus grave que 2008. En
2005, j'étais un des un des rares.
Parfois les journaux me présentent comme
un des cinq qui avaient annoncé la crise
financière. En 2005, on était pas très
nombreux. Dominique Schoscan s'était
moqué de moi devant 400 personnes en
expliquant qu'il y avait aucun risque de
crise, que je m'inquiétais pour rien. Je
montrais le niveau de dette aux
États-Unis, je montrais le taux d'éparne
qui devenait négatif et j'annonçais
qu'on allait vers une crise financière
majeure. Mais à à cette époque-là, le
FMI ou la Banque mondiale ne disait
rien. Tandis que maintenant c'est tous
les mois, tous les mois que le FMI ou la
Banque mondiale nous disent "Attention,
on va vers une crise." Le dernier
rapport de la de la FM du FMI, c'était
la prochaine crise peut avoir des
conséquences 10 fois plus graves. phrase
qui était reprise dans le journal
Lescho, c'est le FMI, d'après le FMI, la
prochaine crise pourrait avoir des
conséquences 10 fois plus graves que
2008. Donc ça pose quand même un
on va on va on va imprimer 10 fois plus
d'argent.
Non non non, c'est c'est trop facile.
Non, c'est voilà quand en souvenez-vous
la crise de 2008, il y a eu 1 million et
dei de chômeurs en France. C'est pas
juste un problème théorique. L'INC me
dit que le chômage fait 15000 morts
chaque année. C'est pas juste un il
suffit pas de faire des des billets
quand des millions de gens tombent au
chômage puis au bout de 2 ans, ils
tombent dans la pauvreté, ben il y en a
qui se relèvent et puis il y en a qui
restent. y compris physiquement
l'incerne dit qu'on on tout le monde
s'en fout mais le le chômage fait des
milliers et des milliers de morts et des
millions de gens qui ont une vie à la
con parce qu'il n'arrivent pas à vivre
dignement.
Voilà et donc ça pose une question quand
même c'est incroyable que le FMI nous
dit qu'on va vers une crise financière
qui pourrait être bien plus grave que
2008 et le JC nous dit attention vous
n'avez plus que quelques années pour
changer le système sinon ce sera trop
tard.
C'est combien d'années ?
Le GC nous dit que c'est à partir de
2020 2021 sans doute qu'il sera trop
tard.
parce qu'il y a des rétroactions qui se
mettent en place. Vous savez par on sait
tous qu'une feuille qui est blanche,
elle renvoie la lumière et la chaleur.
C'estàdire que un truc qui est foncé, il
absorbe la chaleur. Donc quand le
réchauffement fait que la glace du pôle
nord et du pôle sud fond ou la glace de
l'Himalaya fond, donc il y a de moins en
moins de surfaces blanches et de plus en
plus de surfaces foncées. Donc ça
accélère le réchauffement ou bien les
terres qui sont congelées autour du pôle
nord, ce qu'on appelle le permafrost,
elles étaient congelées depuis très
longtemps et le méthane qui était à
l'intérieur restait prisonnier et même
en été ça restait à - 5 ou - 10°gr, il y
avait pas de problème. Et maintenant il
y a 2 mois ou 3 mois dans l'année où le
permafr se décongèle, il s'effondre et
il lâche des quantités de méthane
monstrueuses.
Et les hydrates de méthane sous l'eau.
Mais je vais finir sur le permafrost.
Mais vous avez raison, c'est aussi une
des raisons pour lesquelles le problème
s'agrave. Le bonjour à Total qui
d'ailleurs a très peur quand les
hydrates de métal sautent parce qu'ils
ont l'impression que les Russes font
péter des bombes.
Mais le je finis sur le permafrost mais
c'est un sujet voisin, c'est que le
perma le permafrost lâche des quantités
de méthane. Le méthane, il dure moins
longtemps que le CO2 dans l'atmosphère
mais il a un pouvoir réchauffant
beaucoup plus grave. Son effet de serre
est 14 ou 20 fois plus important
suivant. Donc c'est ça fait partie de
ces on est dans un cercle vicieux et par
ailleurs le problème aussi malgré tous
les beaux discours qu'on fait sur la COP
21 sur la COP 22, la COP 23, les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
tous nos pays continuent à augmenter.
L'an dernier le bilan de la France c'est
+ 3,2. C'est quand même monstrueux et
tout le monde s'en fout. En principe la
France, tout le monde a voté. Tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que le but
c'est la neutralité carbone dans 30 ans.
Donc en principe la France devrait être
tranquillou sur un rythme de - 3 %
chaque année. Et là on n'est pas sur un
rythme de - 3 % ni de -1 ni de on est
sur un rythme de + 3,2. L'an dernier les
chiffres officiels c'est que la France a
émis augmenté de 3 % ses émissions de
gaz effet de serre. Donc c'est pas qu'on
va un peu trop lentement dans le bon
sens, c'est qu'on fait exactement le
contraire de ce qu'il faudrait et tout
le monde s'en fout. Donc nous ce que je
reviens à ce que dit l'UFMI qui dit
qu'on va vers une crise plus grave,
peut-être 10 fois plus grave que 2008.
Donc ça pose quand même une vraie
question. On nous a appris à l'école
qu'on était des homos sapiens sapiens.
Vous souvenez les cours de biologie, on
nous a dit qu'on était la branche la
plus évoluée des primates avec un
cerveau fabuleux. Mais parfois, on se
demande si on est vraiment des sapiens
sapiens ou des débilus débilus parce que
le GC nous prévient qu'on va faire une
crise dramatique. Le FMI nous dit qu'on
va faire une crise 10 fois plus grave
que 2008. Et on est comme des benés, on
est comme des lapins qui regardent le
camion et on sait qu'on va se prendre le
camion, on sait qu'on va se prendre la
crise financière et le chaos climatique.
On a comme complètement tétanisé. Donc
nous ce qu'on veut c'est provoquer un
sursaut.
Les gens sont sont devenus trop cons.
Mais collectivement on est pas
parce que débilus débilus ça veut dire
quoi ?
Je sais pas, j'ai pas fait de latin mais
non mais avouez que c'est troublant.
Encore une fois, les dinosaures, quand
il y a un un météorite qui arrive, ils y
sont pour rien et c'est pas leur faute.
C'estàdire que c'est nous, c'est notre
activité qui on accepte un niveau de
spéculation qu'on a jamais vu. On
continue à avoir de la création
monétaire et c'est à la une des
journaux, c'est le journal Lescho. C'est
pas euh une feuille de chou gauchis,
c'est le journal les échos qui explique
que la prochaine crise aura des
conséquences 10 fois plus graves que
celle de 2008. C'est Christine Lagarde à
Davos qui devant des centaines de VIP
explique qu'on va faire une crise plus
grave, plus rapide et plus générale. Il
y a la coupe de monde du foot. OK, mais
c'est on peut peut-être faire les deux.
Moi aussi,
c'est les Marseillais à Los Angeles.
OK, tout ça, c'est bonnes. Non, mais
c'est un vrai sujet. Est-ce que la
plupart d'entre nous, on passe quand
même quelques heures par jour là à
regarder le football, à inviter des
copains ? Voilà.
Bon, chacun fait ce qu'il veut. Est-ce
que l'avenir de notre planète n'est pas
aussi important ? Moi, j'aimerais que
tous ceux qui disent "Allez, vous venez,
on dit aux copains, vous venez manger
une pizza, on boit un verre de vin et on
rigole ensemble devant le football." Je
trouve c'est une activité qui ça se
défend. Mais peut-être que l'avenir de
notre planète est aussi important que le
football et qu'on pourrait se dire que
de temps en temps, on invite des copains
pour réfléchir sur un truc sérieux, pas
forcément chiant. Ça peut être sérieux
sans être chiant. Et qu'on se dit voyons
le problème climatique, quelles sont les
solutions ? Quels sont les gens qui
posent et comment est-ce qu'on fout la
pression sur Merkel, sur Macron pour
qu'il mettent en place des solutions
vous allez mettre la pression. Et ben
nous notre objectif c'est que pour bras
vos qu dans votre association
et ben écoutez
vous allez vous attaquer la finance
internationale qui a besoin de sa canne
on va dire de de d'injection monétaire
tous les mois pour pouvoir soutenir ces
comportements prédateurs au sein même
d'une guerre économique qui est totale.
On peut dire que tout est foutu mais
alors dans ce cas vous me donnez un
arbre une corde et on cherche un endroit
pour se prendre. Je vous pète les
rotules avant.
D'accord si vous voulez. Monsieur est un
perfectionniste. Je suis un
perfectionniste. Mais non, attendez,
a priori c'est foutu. Je suis panier et
là je suis à jeun. Vous avez une petite
bière, moi je suis à jeun. Je sais
pas de la bière, c'est du gib.
OK. Pardon. A priori c'est foutu. Si
vous regardez le bouquin que j'ai fait
avec Michel Rocard il y a 6 ans, on
expliquait queil y avait une crise
financière nouvelle que la Chine
envahissait Taiïwan. La crise de 29,
elle a débouché sur la barbarie. On
l'oublie. Mais la crise de 29, c'était
une deuxième crise. Il y avait une
première crise financière en 192021 et
puis on s'en était remis assez
facilement. On avait commencé à spéculer
comme des cochons et quand la crise de
29 éclate, c'est monstrueux en terme
social et ça aide les nazis à arriver au
pouvoir et c'est la barbarie. Et là
quand vous voyez la Chine, si vous
voulez vous me réinviter, je vous ferai
vraiment peur avec le niveau de dette en
Chine, l'instabilité sociale et la
course au surarmement et les millions de
chinois qui attendent le match retour
contre les Japonais. Donc a priori, plus
la question du climat et de la
biodiversité, plus Trump à la maison
blanche, plus l'Europe qui se disloque.
A priori, je ne suis pas débile, ça va,
ça peut partir en vrai. A priori, c'est
foutu. Mais comme on est des millions à
comprendre que ça devient grave, comme
on est des millions, il y en a peut-être
quelques milliers même qui vont regarder
notre entretien, il y en a déjà des
milliers qui militent sur ce sujet, je
pour ne pas dire des millions. Non mais
non mais c'est parfois c'est parfois
quand ça devient vraiment grave que les
gens se réveillent. On est des milliers
à aller chez le dentiste. Quand on
commence à voir mal, on nous a
expliquait qu'il faudrait aller chez le
dentiste tous les 6 mois, on le sait
mais en fait on y va uniquement quand on
commence à voir mal. Et c'est peut-être
quand il y a des inondations. J'étais en
Bretagne hier, j'étais à Renn et bien la
Bretagne il y a un mois ils avaient des
inondations monstrueuses, maintenant ils
ont des canicules. Et donc tous ceux qui
expliquaient que le problème climatique
c'était de la blague, maintenant ils
viennent pour en débattre. Voilà, il y a
il y a toutes les tous les quasiment
tous les jours des villes qui approuvent
notre traité et c'est parfois des élus
qui nous disent il y a 4 ou 5 ans, je
m'en fout. L'autre jour à l'Assemblée,
on a plusieurs députés qui nous ont dit
"J'ai découvert aujourd'hui la gravité
du problème." Certains de leurs
collègues étaient effarés parce qu'il y
a des voilà mais on a fait 1h et3
d'audition avec Jean-Josel devant
l'Assemblée nationale devant deux
commissions et plusieurs députés nous
ont dit "J'ai découvert aujourd'hui la
gravité du problème." Donc en une heure,
ils ont découvert la gravité du problème
et le fait qu'il y ait peut-être des
solutions. Si on change les règles du
jeu, il y a besoin d'un changement
radical des règles du jeu. Quand
l'argent donc je je j'y reviens quand
même. Quand il y a 2500 milliards au
total 2500 milliards qui ont été créés
est-ce que on se dit que c'est normal
que ça aille à la spéculation ou est-ce
qu'on se dit que puisque madame Merkel
et monsieur Mac
c'est c'est 1000 1000 milliards par an
là en gros c'était 1000 milliards par an
c'est facile depuis 2 ans et demi le
elle va un peu réduire le la BCE va
réduire mais vraiment il y a eu un
pendant plusieurs années de suite il y
avait
non vous Oui. Je sais bien que c'était
1000 milliards par an le LTO et toutin.
Vous vous demandez combien ? 1000
milliards par an aussi.
Non 1000 milliards c'est quand la Cour
des comptes européenne dit que c'est
1000 milliards. C'est en même temps des
financements privés et des financements
publics.
D'un coup sur combien de temps ?
En fait le vrai problème d'abord je ne
suis pas devant sinon vous vous seriez
devant moi. Voilà je prétends pas avoir
ni trouvé la baguette magique ni savoir
tout précisément à 0 ou 2 % près comment
ça va se passer. Ce qu'on veut c'est
créer une dynamique. Ce qu'on veut
vous voulez pas attendre un élément
exotique fédérateur douloureux. C'est
ça.
Voilà. Je pense que c'est
une catastrophe, une inondation, un
barrage qui éclate.
Non mais attendez, des catastrophes, il
y en a quand même des millions d'hommes
et de femmes qui ne peuvent plus vivre
dignement en Afrique quand même. Il y a
des milli on regarde
l'an dernier aux États-Unis, il y a eu
plus de 300 milliards de dégâts. 300
milliards de dégâts, vous avez vu les
ouragans et on continue à ne rien faire.
Donc
ça coûte moins cher de payer 300
milliards.
Non, c'est faux. Non, c'est maintenant
ça devient faux. Maintenant le coût de
c'est pas de la destruction créatrice.
Ça c'est le les théories. Je crois qu'il
y a plus grand monde qui peter p à ses
cendres. Je crois qu'il y a plus grand
monde qui y croit ni sur la question du
climat ni sur globalement la question du
de
et sur la finance. Donc notre objectif,
je redevient sérieux, c'est d'avoir un
traité européen qui dit la création
monétaire au lieu d'aller n'importe où
et surtout à la spéculation, elle va
financer des créations d'emploi pour
éviter une catastrophe climatique. Donc
ça veut dire concrètement qu'on crée une
banque, on ne touche pas à la BCE parce
que symboliquement on nous explique a
des pays où c'est juste impossible
d'imaginer. Mais on veut juste à côté de
la BCE, vous savez qu' est la BUI, la
Banque européenne d'investissement et on
veut que le traité qui sera approuvé
dans quelques mois dise que la BUI
devient une banque du développement
durable qui est là pour financer la
transition dans tous nos pays.
Donc vous demandez un effort de guerre.
Oui,
clairement
la réponse est oui. Euh les les
civils commence à peine à toucher du
doigt ce qui est en train de se passer.
On parle encore moins des élus.
Est-ce que vous comptez faire, je sais
pas des calendriers, des défilés,
une G Pride ? Vous voulez vous comptez
faire quoi pour sensibiliser vraiment et
ensuite pouvoir faire pression sur les
gouvernements, sur les banques ?
Pour le moment, on est dans le
calendrier, pardon, on est dans le
calendrier institutionnel puisque encore
la semaine dernière, Angela Merkel et
Emmanuel Macron le 19 juin se sont
retrouvés à Berlin et on dit qu'il
commence à comprendre vu ce qui se passe
en Italie, vu ce qui se passe en
Allemagne.
Oui, il commence à comprendre. Bien sûr
que ils comprennent depuis des années,
vous achetez le bouquin de la CIA qui
est publié une fois par an sur les
prévisions, ça fait 30 ans que c'est
marqué dessus. Donc ils sont
parfaitement
non pardon les troubles politiques,
pardon sur le fond vous avez raison mais
sur les troubles les troubles
politiques, ce qui se passe en Italie
avec des néonazi qui arrive au pouvoir
et voilà c'est quand même quelque chose
de nouveau et de vraiment inquiétant la
contagion. Non non c'est pas l'écume des
choses ça peut provoquer
d'accord ça fait 30 ans que c'est marqué
noir sur blanc dans le bouquin de la
CIA.
Je ne lis pas le bouquin de la CIA. Non
mais sans rire ça m'intéresse. Ouais ce
serait bien de commencer. OK ?
Donc là, ça vous évitera de dire que ça
vous éviterait de dire que Macron et
Angel Merkel sont en train de prendre
conscience du problème. Ça fait des
décennies que les services de
renseignement s'inquiète sur ce
sujet-là. Je prends l'exemple sur les
impacts du réchauffement climatique sur
le livre plan de la défense française,
une conférence qui a été fait au collège
intéarmé de défense en 2008. Ça fait des
années qu'on s'y intéresse.
Tout à fait.
Donc là, on vous voit gentiment en train
de vous agiter avec Jean-Josel. Tout va
bien. Qu'est-ce qui va réellement les
faire plier ? Vous allez vous pointer
avec des fleurs dans votre fusil, vous
allez les attraper ? Vous allez faire
quoi ? D'abord les convaincre. On veut
dire à madame Merqued,
c'est pas des incantations que vous êtes
en train de nous faire là.
Mais écoutez là, je je peux pas trahir
le secret des discussions en cours, mais
par le nouveau premier ministre
espagnol, c'est un des premiers qui a
signé notre pacte. Je vais à Madrid dans
quelques jours, je vais rencontrer deux
des ministres de de Pedro Sanchez et un
très très proche conseiller de Petro
Sanchez. Donc on a des alliés parmi ceux
qui sont autour de la de la table du
conseil et après ça Angela Merkel,
Emmanuel Macron commencent à comprendre.
Je pense que la situation
ils ont déjà bien compris depuis des
décennies hein.
Non, il y a une aggravation peut-être.
OK, il y a eu des rapports pour dire que
le problème du climat devenait
monstrueux. Il y a eu les services tout
ce que vous dites est sans doute vrai.
Mais
c'est c'est pas sans doute, c'est vrai.
Et c'est vrai, pardon, c'est vrai. Mais
non, on est pas dans un débat politique
là.
Non, non, mais pardon. Oui, le GC dit
depuis 30 ans, je ne connais pas pendant
je vous je vous connais que depuis une
heure donc je ne vous mais je vous fais
confiance a priori mais on peut dire que
même sans parler des services secrets le
JC a été créé il y a 30 ans. Ronald Ran
et Scher ont dû accepter de créer le JC
alors qu'il ne le voulaient pas
justement à cause des travaux de Jean
Jusel de Claude Lorius qui ont montré
l'évidence du lien entre le CO2 et la
température. Donc, ce sont les travaux
de Jean-Josel, de Claude Lorius et de
quelques autres qui ont été tellement
évidents sur le lien entre CO2 et
réchauffement climatique que 6 mois plus
tard, Satcher, Rigan ont dû accepter de
créer le JC et que dès son deuxème
rapport, le JC a dit attention, il y a
un moment où il sera trop tard. En gros,
le JC a dit ce sera sans doute dans 25
ans. Donc en 2020 il y a 25 ans.
Voilà. Maintenant c'est dans 2 ans mais
à l'époque c'était dans 25 ans. Donc les
il y a un moment où il y a pas un jour
on va entendre un gros craquement mais à
cause des cercles vicieux dont on a
parlé il y a 10 minutes, à cause des
rétroactions, la glace qu' font le
permafrost, il y a un moment où ça va
s'emballer. Donc on est proche de ce
moment. C'est pour ça que vous et moi on
sent qu'il y a de la gravité. C'est pour
ça qu'on est stressé. On est obligé de
gagner. On n pas le choix. Il faut qu'on
gagne la bataille. Et un des trucs qui
nous fait espérer que peut-être qu'on
peut y arriver par la voie légale, par
la voix normale, c'est le fait que
Merkel, Macron et les autres chefs
d'État comprennent maintenant parce que
ce qui se passe en Italie, désolé mais
le gouvernement actuel, c'est quand même
pas la même chose que le gouvernement
d'Enrico Letta. Voilà. Non mais le vote
quand on voit un un parti néonazi et un
parti le mouvement 5 étoiles, il y a en
même temps des gens très bien et des
gens très bizarres
pour vous c'est l'écume des choses. Mais
il se trouve que des pays peuvent se
disloquer quand leur gouvernement
des continents aussi
des continents aussi nous autres
civilisations savons que nous sommes
mortels et vous et moi on peut voir
l'effond
dislocation géopolitique majeure.
Oui la réponse est oui. Mais est-ce
qu'on commmente est-ce qu'on juste on
fait des commentaires là-dessus sur le
fait que cher amis nous allons connaître
une dislocation majeure ou est-ce qu'on
se dit
est-ce que j'ai une tête à faire cher
ami non mais pardon juste le but en plus
on est d'accord à 95 % sur la gravité de
la situation c'est comment est-ce qu'on
pousse les gens à ne pas se décourager
si chacun reste chez soi voir
l'immensité des problèmes il y a de quoi
se flinguer ou tomber en dépression
est-ce qu'on se rassemble et est-ce
qu'on est capable de se dire il y a un
endroit où on peut agir pour obtenir une
victoire
là je sens ton petit passage chez les
écologistes on se rassent Bon moi je
vais poser une question
1989 il y a ton économiste qui t'a dit
que il allait jamais s'effondrer pour
les 50 prochaines années. Il y a pas de
problème. T'inquiète t'inquiète
t'inquiète. D'accord on se connaît pas
mais t'inquiète pas on a fait ton
pédigré.
Donc moi je te pose la question c'est
comment tu vas mettre la pression sur
les politiques ?
La première étape, c'est qu'on profite,
on on fait du judo politique puisque
Angué Merkel et Emmanuel Macron ont dit
que c'est cette année, le 13 et le 14
décembre qu'il faut décider des nouveaux
traités. Merel et Macron l'ont redit la
semaine dernière, le 19 juin, à Berlin,
qu'on n'est pas dans une année de
routine, on est dans une année
historique. Angela Merkel, Emmanuel
Macron disent c'est on demande aux
citoyens, en plus, ils disent on demande
aux citoyens jusqu'au 30 octobre de dire
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent. Début
novembre, madame Merkel, monsieur
Macron, monsieur Sanchez feront le bilan
des débats citoyens. et diront ce qui
mettent sur la table du débat le 13 et
le 14 décembre. Et Merkel a dit qu'il
faudrait sans doute des nouveaux traités
qui seraient ratifiés l'année prochaine.
Donc on peut ne pas les croire
2019.
Voilà. Et nous notre objectif c'est
queon est un traité soit le climat qui
crée une banque du climat au niveau
européen. Souviens-toi ou souvenez-vous
quand le mur de Berlin est tombé il a
suffi de 6 mois. Elmoucol et François
Mitteran en 6 mois seulement ont créé
une banque pour financer la transition
des pays. À l'époque c'était pas la
transition écologique, c'était juste la
transition des pays exsoviétique. Donc
quand ils ont eu la trouille, quand ils
ont vu un truc qui qui était qui qui
était historique, il a suffi de 6 mois
pour créer une banque pour financer la
transition. Et donc nous ce qu'on veut
c'est que l'année prochaine, il y a une
banque qui soit créée. En plus on ne
part pas de rien du tout. On partirait
de la BUI qui existe déjà qui est déjà
notée aa et on montre que en 6 mois on
peut créer une banque qui va financer la
transition en Europe et en Afrique elle
est noté à
par les agences de notation. Ça veut
dire qu'elle peut ça veut dire qu'elle
peut fournir des toit des prêts à taux
zéro à tous ceux qui en auront besoin.
D'accord. Bon on va recontextualiser
donc comment et comment on fait pression
pardon il y a 6 mois on n'existait pas
personne connaissait notre projet et là
on a déjà 50 députés rien qu'en France.
Il a suffit qu'on qu'on envoie quelques
mails, qu'on fasse une réunion à
l'UNESCO, qu'on soit Du coup, on est
auditionné par deux commissions. Du
coup, les deux présidentes disent
qu'elles signent alors qu'elle
connaissait pas le projet quelques
semaines avant. On est auditionné dans
quelques temps par le groupe des députés
franco-allemands. Euh notre objectif,
c'est qu'on est en France, en Allemagne,
en Espagne, assez de parlementaires de
tous horizons qui disent "Putain, on y
va maintenant." Comment tu vas toucher
la pleb ? Tu vas engager Sophie Marceau
cette magnifique jeune.
Je souhaite rencontrer Sophie Marceau
depuis très longtemps pour plein raison.
Non Sophie, on passe un message.
Oui, je suis très heureux de rencontrer.
Du coup, je parle face à la caméra,
j'aurais dû voilà donc la réponse est
oui. On cherche. Non mais je redeviens
sérieux. Je veux bien dans mes jeux bien
Oui, la réponse est oui. Non, mais je
suis tout à fait sérieux. On veut que
Sophie Marceau et Mar s'engage Audre
tout.
La réponse est oui parce que c'est très
bien. On va voir des prix Nobel. On a
des gens de Normal Sup qui bossent avec
nous en économie pour faire un rapport
pour montrer à quel point c'est soit en
matière économique. On aura des chefs
d'entreprise, votre question à 10
minutes. On a déjà quelques grands
patrons, pas tous évidemment. Il y en a
qui sont pas d'accord. Mais on a déjà
quelques grands patrons qui disent
qu'ils veulent nous aider et on voudrait
en octobre, en novembre pouvoir montrer
qu'on a en même temps des grands
patrons, en même temps des mouvements de
chômeur qui disent "Ce serait génial, ça
va créer des emplois en même temps
Sophie Marceau et au Marcis." Oui.
Oui. Non, plutôt Sophie Marceau et
Audrot tout.
Ça me va très bien.
Euh on va te recontextualiser un petit
peu ton petit problème. Donc là, tu
demandes un peu de pognon 1000
milliards.
Pardon, j'ai fait que il y a deux
parties dans notre plan comme vous le
savez. Il y a l'aspect banque et puis
l'aspect il y a l'aspect euh créer un
impôt sur les bénéfices pour avoir de
l'argent du budget de l'argent qu'on
peut consommer et pas seulement des prêt
à zéro. Mais j'écoute votre question.
C'est pas une question, on va te
contextualiser. On va essayer de te
faire comprendre notre prisme de
lecture. Là les économies sont
moribondes.
On vit à crédit c'est-à-dire qu'on on
est en train d'imprimer des promesses de
de calories futures ou de travail futur.
Tu es un peu spécialisé dans le pétrole
aussi. Tu dois comprendre ce que je
raconte là. un tout petit peu.
Un tout petit peu là euh tu as pas
l'impression de faire peur un peu au
milieu bancaire qui tient déjà d'une
façon très précaire qui a déjà des taux
un niveau de dette très précaire ? Tu as
pas l'impression que on a passé le point
de nos retour au niveau financier ? On
n'évitera pas une crise financière.
Merci de le dire.
Non mais il se trouve que je répète sans
vouloir me vanter qu'en 2003 déjà
j'avais expliqué j'avais fait une grve
de la fin en 2005 avec quelques amis.
Combien de temps tuas combien de temps
tu as tenu ?
Une semaine seulement. C'est petits
joueurs quoi.
Oui, pardon mais je on fait ce qu'on
peut. Euh voilà et à l'époque certains
me prenaient vraiment pour un charlot.
Je répète Dominique Schroscan s'est
foutu de ma gueule devant 400 personnes
en expliquant qu'il y avait aucun risque
de crise que je m'inquiétais pour rien.
Il a bien payé là.
Euh voilà donc oui, on on é quand on
voit le niveau de il y a deux problèmes.
Quand on voit le niveau de spéculation
en France, on a le CAC 40. Aux
États-Unis, il y a le Dow Jones. La
dernière fois que le do s'était effondré
en 2008, le doit monté à 14000 points
avant de s'effondrer. Maintenant, il est
24000. Voilà. Donc, on a jamais vu
autant de spéculation. Et en plus, ce
qui est plus grave, on n'a jamais vu
autant de dettes par la Chine qui est le
moteur de l'économie mondiale, la dette
totale publique et privé et sans compter
les comptes bizarres, ce qu'on appelle
le shadow banking, les trucs vous mettez
un milliard mais on on met pas dans la
dans les trucs officiels. Donc rien que
les la comptabilité officielle dette
publique et dette privée, on est passé
en 20 ans d'une dette de 100 % du PIB à
250 % du PIB. Voilà.
Comme le Japon.
Le Japon c'est la dette publique. Oui,
le Japon est une dette publique
monstrueuse et n'arrive pas pour Japon
vient de dire qu'il est retombé en
récession. Voilà, mais on peut pas
espérance de vie de du moins une
démographie en baisseement
des populations. Voilà. Mais si on en
revient au risque de crise financière
puis ça à votre question on joue avec le
feu. 2008 n'a servi à rien. C'est
Stiglitz le prix Nobel qui dit queon
s'est contenté de déplacer les fauteuils
sur le pont du Titanic. Mais le Titanic
continue et le FMI nous dit
le FMI le FMI le FMI nous dit le
l'économie mondiale est comme le
Titanic, elle accélère avant le choc.
Voilà donc c'est des critiques qui
étaient avant une partie de la gauche
une avec Michel Rocard j'avais écrit ça
et voilà et maintenant c'est même le FMI
qui nous dit l'économie mondiale est
comme le Titanic, elle accélère avant le
choc. Donc encore une fois est-ce qu'on
est capable de secouer de façon non
violente ? Vous avez reçu John Palais
l'autre jour, c'est un ami. Je pense
qu'il faut de façon non violente.
J'étais ce matin à Ber, on était avec
Jean-Josel à Ber devant une centaine de
salariés du ministère des finances et il
y avait là quelqu'un qui m'a dit au bout
d'un moment "Mais quand est-ce que vous
descendez dans la rue ?" Voilà. Donc en
même temps, un haut fonctionnaire qui
veut nous aider pour techniquement
montrer qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire au
niveau européen. Il pense qu'il faut en
même temps gagner la bataille de la
crédibilité, qu'il faut rassembler le
camp progressiste. C'est c'est aussi ce
que dit Chetch d'Alternativa, c'est
qu'il faut l'initiative qu'on porte,
elle a l'intérêt de rassembler tous les
progressistes et peut-être d'arriver à
une victoire alors que quand même depuis
quelques décennies, les progressistes
sont très très divisés et vendent
d'échecs en effet.
Donc si si on n'y arrive pas, qu'est-ce
qui se passe au niveau des guerres, des
flux migratoires de la signification ?
C'est le le truc le le la Banque
mondiale dit qu'on aura 140 millions de
réfugiés climatiques
au minimum.
Au minimum. Le MIT rappelle que le corps
humain ne sait pas faire du froid, que
donc quand il fait que pour maintenir
notre cerveau et notre foi à température
correcte, on évapore de l'eau. Voilà,
quand il fait chaud, on évapore, ça
marche sauf si l'air est en même temps
trop chaud et trop humide. Et donc si
l'air est en même temps trop chaud et
trop humide, l'évaporation ça ne marche
plus et donc le corps humain monte en
température et c'est insupportable. Je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez, l'an
dernier, il y a eu pendant quelques
jours ce genre de canicule en Chine et
c'était l'horreur. On voyait des hommes
et des femmes qui allaient mendier un
peu de fraîcheur, qui se plaquaient sur
le sol en espérant un peu de fraîcheur,
qui ne trouvaient pas. Parce que quand
jour et nuit et jour et nuit, il fait
trop chaud et trop humide, on pète les
plombs, ça n'est pas possible. Et le MIT
nous dit que d'ici 50 60 70 ans, une
partie de l'Asie sera inhabitable à
cause de ces cadicules chaudes et
humides pendant plusieurs mois dans dans
l'année. Donc on va vers une souffrance
humaine, des millions d'hommes et de
femmes qui vont souffrir au quotidien,
certains qui vont mourir sur place et
d'autres qui vont se déplacer parce
qu'ils auront pas envie de mourir. Donc
c'est pas pour rien si le G a eu le prix
Nobel de la paix, ils n'ont pas eu le
prix Nobel de physique chimie hein. Ils
analysent le CO2, ils analysent le
méthane mais ils ont pas eu un prix
Nobel scientifique. Ils ont eu le prix
Nobel de la paix parce que ce qui est en
jeu c'est bien la paix mondiale dans les
20 ans qui viennent. Et quand on voit le
bazar qui est en Italie et notre
incapacité à accueillir 1 million de
réfugiés, moi j'en ai honte. Quand
j'étais petit, quand j'étais adolescent,
on avait trois botes people à la maison.
papa travailler à EDF, on avait une
maison correcte, on avait accueilli
trois réfugiés et on vivait très bien.
Et la France voilà, on avait la France
globalement avait accueilli 150000
réfugiés, 150000 jeunes vieux qui
avaient besoin de vivre voilà et
maintenant on est deux fois ou trois
fois plus riche et on a peur
d'accueillir 100000 ou 200000 personnes.
Tu vois quand tu vois Donald Trump
construire des murs, faire des milices,
utiliser de la big data, utiliser
l'arsenal législatif pour pouvoir
réquisitionner des bases militaires pour
faire des camps de de rétention
administrative ou des camps
d'internement,
ça te fait penser à quoi ?
Ça fait peur. Ça veut dire que la bête
immonde, comme on dit, n'est pas morte
et que ce que les les la barbarie qu'on
a connu dans les années 30 et les années
40 peut très bien revenir. Il y a eu
aucun progrès moral dans nos têtes, dans
nos consciences. C'est rien qui nous
garantit queon va pas connaître une
barbarie avec une puissance décuplée. Tu
as déjà été à Mayotte ?
Non. À Seouta ?
Non.
Est-ce que tu as déjà vu la hauteur des
barbelés àoutain ?
Oui, j'ai vu des images et c'est
horrible. Et donc c'est bien, on a
raison de critiquer Trump et
heureusement quelques millions
d'Américains le font aussi.
J'allais dire est-ce que l'Europe est à
la hauteur et est-ce que l'Europe est
capable de montrer non pas en théorie
dans une discussion
est-ce qu'elle est capable ou est-ce
qu'elle peut ?
Elle peut à coup sûr. Donc ça il y a
aucun doute sur le fait qu'elle peut. La
question, est-ce qu'on a la volonté
politique ? Est-ce
peut quand quand on voit 1 million de de
migrants débarquer en Allemagne avec
entre 5 et 11 % qui trouvent du boulot ?
Non mais ça c'est une vision globale. Je
je reviens dans les 3 semaines pour
expliquer comment Oui. Non mais pardon,
est-ce que un espace où il y a 500
millions d'habitants d'abord pourquoi
est-ce que c'est uniquement l'Allemagne
qui en a accueilli ? Si on avait mieux
réparti les les réfugiés, peut-être
qu'on aurait il y a eu moins aurait
moins de concentration et même est-ce
qu'on se donne des moyens de lutter
contre le chômage et la précarité ?
Est-ce qu'on donne les moyens de
construire assez de logement ? Parce que
si on met les gens en concurrence, s'il
y a pas du travail pour tout le monde,
s'il y a pas des logements pour tout le
monde, et bien on sait tous qu'on a un
cerveau reptilien et qu'au bout d'un
moment, on a marre parce qu'on est en
concurrence. Parce que moi, je connais
quelqu'un dans mon quartier qui attend
depuis 20 ans un logement social. Cette
dame n'est pas du tout raciste, mais
voilà, elle dit que il y a comme il y a
pas assez de logement, elle elle voit
des gens qui lui passent devant et c'est
plutôt effectivement des familles
noires. Il y a aucun doute là-dessus. Et
donc est-ce que le problème c'est les
familles noires ou est-ce que le
problème c'est qu'on ne construit pas
assez le logement qu'on est dans un pays
où il y a des milliards où on est tout à
tout à fait
si on construit on consomme.
Mais si on construit mon sujet c'est
juste voilà il y a quand on dit qu' j'ai
suis fatigué
l'épuisement des matières premières
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Non mais le fait qu'on construise pardon
on peut très bien construire des
logements pour tout le monde et éviter
que les gens soient en compétition pour
des logements et du coup on serait pas
discriminé. Le débat sur oui mais si on
accueille des réfugiés ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas de logement pour les gens
de chez nous. C'est un débat à la con.
C'est un débat parce que juste on met
les ch
ou légitime
parce qu'on c'est parce qu'on ne
construit pas suffisamment, je suis
désolé. C'est parce qu'on concentre si
l'Allemagne n'avait pas été la seule à
accueillir des réfugiés mais si la
France avait pris sa part, si on avait
pas laissé l'Italie ou l'Allemagne
accueillir autant de réfugiés, si on
avait mieux réparti et si par ailleurs
en mettant en place quelques idées que
je porte avec d'autres sur la lutte
entre le chômage, je suis désolé.
Tu vois, il y a des il y a des villes
qui payent des amendes parce qu'ils ont
pas suffisamment de logements sociaux.
Oui, mais ça veut peut-être dire qu'il
faut que le préfet plus de pouvoir qu'on
ne peut pas quelqu'un qui ne il faut
peut-être durcir la loi et le faire
respecter la loi. On a besoin de justice
sociale, on a besoin d'équité, on a
besoin que tout
ça peut faire une guoïisation.
Non, c'est justement la ghétisation
c'est s'il y a 40 % de gens en situation
très difficile dans certains quartiers
et que à 30 km il y a des ghetos de
riches où on ne voit aucune aucune
personne en situation précaire. C'est ça
la ghettoisation. Par contre si dans
tous les quartiers, dans tous les pâtés
de maison
tu n'as pas parlé que le réchauffement
climatique allait creuser les
inégalités. Oui, je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure que c'était un problème de jus
de justice sociale et climatique que ce
sont aujourd'hui, j'en ai parlé sur les
problèmes de précarité énergétique.
Aujourd'hui, ce sont les pays les plus
pauvres qui sont les plus touchés et
dans chaque pays, ce sont les plus
pauvres. On le voit aux États-Unis quand
il y a un ouragan, ceux qui morfl ce
sont les pays les plus pauvres et
souvent qui ont une couleur de peau un
peu plus foncée que que la mienne et que
par contre les plus riches et ceux qui
ont une couleur de foncé couleur de peau
comme la mienne s'en sortent mieux. Et
donc il y a des inégalités croissantes
entre pays et au sein de chaque pays. Ce
sont les plus pauvres qui morfl. Mais ça
n'est pas une fatalité. C'est une
question de choix politique. Et je
reviens sur la question des réfugiés.
Est-ce que d'abord on se donne les
moyens d'accueillir ceux qui viennent ?
Encore une fois, la France a été capable
il y a 30 ans ou 40 ans d'accueillir 30
ans 35 ans d'accueillir 150000 réfugiés
et maintenant on est deux fois plus
riche donc on pourrait accueillir sans
problème et puis est-ce qu'on se donne
les moyens de lutter contre c'est pas de
gaié de cœur que les gens quittent leur
pays. Il y a aussi un droit à vivre dans
son pays. Moi je n'aime je je pense
qu'il faut tout faire pour que quelqu'un
qui est né en Afrique, quelqu'un qui est
né en Asie puisse vivre dignement dans
son travail de dans son pays. Mais ça
suppose de changer beaucoup de choses.
Ça suppose ça suppose de changer nos
politiques agricoles, nos politiques
d'exportation. Est-ce que ça suppose
aussi de faire changer dans la tête des
gens leur façon de consommer, de vivre,
leurs idéaux ? Est-ce que ça fait pas 40
ans qu'on leur met le rêve américain
d'avoir 50 paires de de godasse, de
vivre, d'avoir un idéal de rouler en
super Porsche une super voiture ?
Oui.
Est-ce que l'inertie sociétale au niveau
de cette frugalité, c'est pas trop tard
quand tu vois ? Je crois qu'il y a quand
même
l'idéal l'idéal féminin euh porté par la
société de consommation. Quand tu vois
l'idéal masculin porté par la société de
consommation,
je crois qu'il y a des choses qui bouge
quand je crois qu'il y a de moins en
moins de gens qui sont attachés à avoir
leur voiture. Je crois que par il y a
autrefois tout le monde, tous ceux qui
avaient un peu de sous voulaient avoir
leur voiture et la plus grosse voiture
possible. Et je crois quand même qu'il y
a de plus en plus de gens qui disent je
pas forcément besoin d'une voiture en
permanence. Donc
ça veut dire que quand les femmes
choisiront les meilleurs d'entre nous,
le monde ira mieux. Vaste question. Mais
euh peut-être, mais je pense que femme
et homme, je pense qu'il y a une
perception des problèmes qui est en
train d'évoluer et je pense que le
modèle euh
je veux une grosse voiture qui pollue
beaucoup
pour séduire une belle femme.
Ouais. Ben, je crois que c'est en train
de changer. Je peut-être que je suis
trop optimiste, mais dans les gens que
je rencontre peut-être que c'est une
partie de la population et puis je pense
que les gens murissent. Enfin, je pense
qu'il y a moi je
pas beaucoup vu d'avion de chasse à
Notred Dame d'éland quand même hein.
Non mais je pardon, moi je crois au
dialogue. Pardon, c'est pour ça que je
je suis peut-être pas très clair
aujourd'hui. Je suis j'ai peu dormi la
nuit dernière parce qu'on a fini très
tard à Renn et ce matin, j'ai commencé
très tôt au ministère des finances. Mais
je crois au dialogue. J'arrive partout
avec mes petits graphiques et je crois
que les gens sont capables de comprendre
qu'and l'autre jour plusieurs députés
nous disent qu'ils ont compris ce
jour-là la gravité du problème et qu'ils
ont compris qu'il y avait des solutions
et c'était une opportunité, ben je me
suis dit j'ai pas perdu ma matinée. Et
c'est pour ça aussi que je voudrais
qu'on soit le plus nombreux de
porte-parole. Il y a des étudiants qui
se forment dans notre association pour
être porte-parole de ce message dans
leurs universités.
Est-ce que tu envisages la confrontation
avec les politiques ?
ferme
par exemple, admettons que tu arrives à
fédérer sur ta page Facebook, YouTube ou
tes réseaux sociaux 3 millions de
personnes et que tu organises une flash
mob pour te donner rendez-vous
auprès des sep voitures de notre
ministère des é de l'écologie de Nicol
juste avant la COP
Nicolas Hul, tu l'as eu au téléphone ?
Je l'ai pas eu au téléphone, je l'ai
rencontré plusieurs fois. Il a fait la
préface de notre livre.
D'accord. Et donc je pense peut-être que
si on a on verra début novembre si
Emmanuel Macron a repris notre projet ou
pas et sinon peut-être je qu'il faudra
faire un être place de la République
faire une grande marche non violente
juste avant le sommet des chefs d'État
européens déjà en Belgique des copains
veulent organiser ça.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses qu'on fiche les
écologistes
les fichiers S ?
Comment ça se fait comment ça se fait
qu'on fiche les écologistes ?
J'étais pas au courant. Pardon je
découvre le sujet
mais peut-être que je suis fiché je ne
sais pas.
Est-ce que tu trouves est-ce que tu
trouves que les mouvements écologistes
qui portent atteinte au aux intérêts
nationaux, c'est normal qu'on les fiche
?
Mais de quel de qui on parle ? Pardon,
je découvre le sujet.
Ceux qui s'amusent, tu découvres le
sujet.
Oui, pardon, pardon, je aucun de tout
suivre. Peut-être que tu as jamais
entendu parler.
Non, pardon. Non, non, je
les gens de chez Greenpeace par exemple,
les gens che
Non, je ne savais pas qu'ils étaient
fichés. Non, je vous m'apprenez que ils
sont fichés
au même titre que certains terroristes.
Ben, je trouve ça tout à fait choquant
qu'on les met dans les mêmes cases que
des terroristes.
Pourquoi ?
Ben parce que
est-ce que est-ce que menacer les
entreprises françaises polluantes, c'est
menacé la croissance ? Donc c'est menacé
la la France, on peut pas du tout le
mettre au même niveau. On peut pas du
tout le même mettre au même niveau que
les terroristes. Les actions non
violentes pour dire qu'il faut stopper
les subventions aux énergies fossiles,
c'est quand même quelque chose qui va
dans le bon sens et c'est aucun rapport
avec une action terroriste. Donc je suis
un peu étonné quand vous me dites qu'ils
sont fichés. Et les les
moi j'étais à Notre Dame des Landes, je
me suis pris des lacrymogènes, j'étais à
Notre Dame des Landes, j'étais à Sivin
voilà et je
Tu as pas dû rester longtemps, tu as
fait une après-midi quoi.
Je suis allé trois fois à Notreddame des
Landes. Et
trois fois trois petites après-midis
quoi
et oui je oui je pas
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de
l'enfouissement des déchets radioactifs
?
Je pense que c'est son J'ai pas beaucoup
réfléchi du point de vue technique mais
je pense que ce n'est pas la meilleure
je pense que le nucléaire aujourd'hui
les avantages mon père travaillé EDF.
Quand j'étais petit, on on m'expliquait
que le nucléaire nous nous donnait une
énergie pas trop chère qui était nous
garantissait une autonomie
la France et on nous papa nous expliqué
que les énergies renouvelables étaient
beaucoup trop chères. Ça c'était vrai il
y a 40 ou 45 ans, mais aujourd'hui le
prix des énergies renouvelables s'est
effondré parce qu'il y a des gens qui
font progresser l'éolien, le
photovoltaïque, la biomasse et le prix
du nucléaire augmente parce que après
les accidents qui ont eu lieu en Russie
ou au Japon, on veut des normes de plus
en plus élevé et le coût de l'EPR
augmente à chaque fois qu'on fait un
EPR. Donc je crois que même du point de
vue bêtement économique, on voit que le
modèle du nucléaire n'est plus le bon
modèle. Donc c'est pas pour rien si on
se dit qu'il faut progressivement sortir
du nucléaire et ça suppose de l'effic de
la sobriété. Il en gros il faut diviser
par de notre consommation d'énergie. Si
chacun de nous passe son temps à
regarder sur internet des vidéos. Si
chacun de nous veut avoir une voiture,
si chacun de nous laisse le les lumières
allumées parce que c'est pas grave voilà
il on on s'en sortira pas. Même avec des
énergies renouvelables, on s'en sortira
pas. Donc l'objectif c'est de diviser
par de notre consommation d'énergie et
que ces énergies qu'on stoppe
l'exploitation du du charbon du fiel de
ce qui des énergies carbonées fossiles
et qu'on l'énergie dont on a besoin
qu'on qu'on le fasse avec des énergies.
Com tu consommes toi ?
Aucune idée.
Je prends ce
que tu manges tes chaussures, le prix de
ton costard. Mon costume est nouveau,
pas je passe à la télé mais sinon le le
jour ma femme m'a engueulé parce j'ai
toujours des trucs qui dépassent et le
même costume que j'ai faré trois fois
mais là je voilà mais sinon euh je la
sobriété c'est réellement le vieux jean
bien troué voilà je n'ai jamais acheté
de voiture j'ai eu la chance que de
récupérer des vieilles voitures. Je
n'utilise jamais la voiture sauf une
fois par an pour partir dans les
pyrénées.
V comment aujourd'hui
là je suis venu en métro évidemment j'ai
un navigo. Je peux le prouver. Euh voilà
mais de toute façon dans Paris
de la viande.
Oui encore trop souvent. Je suis un bon
berné élevé au jambon de Bayonne. Donc
je je j'en consomme moins qu'il y a 10
ans mais j'en consomme encore trop. Oui.
Oui. Par contre, je ne prends jamais
l'avion sauf quand on m'invite pour
aller à Bamaco ou qu'on m'invite à la
Réunion pour pour parler du climat. Mais
sinon, ça fait des années et des années
que je n'ai pas pris l'avion et je
trouve ça tout à fait normal.
Donc revenons à l'idéal qu'on a
instylé
instillé dans dans la dans l'inconscient
des gens d'hyperconsommation
pour d'ailleurs soutenir un système
financier
hyper consommant. Oui et ça revient
pendant avec ça revient avec l'idée
fausse que s'il y a pas de croissance on
peut pas donner du boule à tout le
monde. C'est pas pour rien. Je crois que
vous avez creusé ma biographie, ça fait
25 ans que je me bas sur l'idée de la
semaine de 4 jours et dire qu'on peut
créer des emplois même sans croissance
qu'avec les projets techniques, avec les
robots, les ordinateurs, avec
l'intelligence qu'on a mis dans la tête
des gens, on produit beaucoup plus avec
moins de travail et qu'au lieu que au
lieu de d'accepter de subir que ces
gains de productivité amènent à un
chômage massif, qu'on pourrait partager
autrement, de façon plus intelligente le
temps de travail sur toute la vie. Et je
trouve qu'il y a 400 entreprises qui ont
mis en place cette idée. Tous les
salariés passent à 4 jours en moyenne et
l'entreprise arrête de payer les
cotisations chômage si elle a créé 10 %
d'emploi. Donc c'est une façon de
montrer qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
croissance parce que cette fuite en
avant quand on dit que la Chine met
toujours plus de dettes et tout ça c'est
avec l'idée que il faut donner du boulot
aux gens sinon le peuple va se rebeller
donc il y a besoin de donner du travail
et la plupart de nos dirigeants pensent
c'est pas possible de donner du travail
aux gens s'il y a pas de croissance et
nous on montre que les leviers les plus
fondament les plus efficaces pour donner
du travail un maximum de gens c'est
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique.
Ça peut créer massivement des emplois et
c'est relancer une négociation sur la
question du temps de travail tout au
long de la vie.
Alors, question internet. Doit-on voter
les lois sur le consumérisme raisonné ?
Je ne sais pas ce qui est cette loi.
Pardon ?
C'est une question.
Autre question. Faut-il nationaliser les
banques pour financer la transition
écologique ?
Non. Par contre, il faut créer une
banque, il faut sans doute faire la
séparation des banques. Si on veut
calmer la spéculation, c'est un des
trucs que Rooswelt avait fait, la
séparation des banques de déployé des
banques d'affaires. Ça ça calmerait le
jeu sur la spéculation.
Exactement. Ça a marché pendant 60 ans
hein quand même mais ça marchait très
bien. Euh et il faut créer une banque au
niveau européen. Donc c'est le traité
qu'on propose dans on peut dans 1 an et
demi avoir une banque du climat au
niveau européen, soit la BUI qu'on
transforme, soit une filiale de la BUI
qui serait une banque pour financer la
transition dans tous les pays d'Europe
et les pays d'Afrique.
Peut-on réussir une transition dans un
scénario où les USA ne suivent pas ? La
réponse est oui. Euh c'est-à-dire que
l'Europe est quand même le la première
économie mondiale. On a l'habitude de se
fouetter, de voir tous nos défauts, mais
on oublie quand même que l'Europe est la
première puissance économique mondiale.
Donc si l'Europe et l'Afrique et la
Méditerranée enclenche ce mouvement,
d'abord c'est quand même une bonne
partie de de l'humanité qui sera
concernée et on pense qu'il y aura un
effet de domino positif. On parle
souvent de l'effet de domino pour une
catastrophe. S'il y a une banque qui
fait faillite, il y a d'autres banques
qui vont faire faillite, mais nous on
pense que si l'Europe fait la preuve
qu'un autre modèle est possible et qu'on
vit bien, on vit bien mais on consomme
beaucoup moins d'énergie,
mais ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas on
peut quand même manger mais on mangera
moins de viande. On peut se déplacer
mais avec des modes de V.
L'apport l'apport énergétique
journalier, tu le fixes à combien ?
J'en sais rien. J'ai pas tous les
chiffres en tête. Pardon, je suis je
suis voilà, je ne vais pas sortir tous
les chiffres, mais
c'est quoi ? C'est 1500 calories, 2000
calories.
Je sais pas, je suis un peu fatigué là.
Pardon vraiment, j'ai fini très tard
hier à Renn et pris le premier TGV pour
arriver sur Paris. Donc je n'ai pas tous
les chiffres. Je sais par contre que
l'objectif c'est de diviser par 4 ou
même d'arriver à la neutralité carbone.
Ce qui suppose, je répète, de diviser
par de notre consommation d'énergie. Et
c'est possible si on isole tous les
bâtiments publics et privés. Si on
arrête d'avoir chacun sa voiture et de
se mettre dans des embouteillages, ça
suppose de prendre le marcher à pied,
prendre le vélo, avoir des transports en
commun et seulement de façon
exceptionnel d'utiliser une voiture qui
sera plus légère, qui ira moins vite et
qui
Comment tu vas les comment tu vas les
les reformer les gens qui vont perdre
leur boulot par exemple dans l'industrie
du charbon, dans l'industrie automobile
?
Et bien, c'est justement pour ça qu'il
faut une une transformation la plus
globale possible pour qu'il y ait
vraiment des créches en emploi massives
à proximité. Parce que un homme ou une
femme qui travaille aujourd'hui dans le
charbon en Allemagne ou en Pologne, il
faut qu'on puisse lui dire que vraiment
pas en théorie mais que pour de vrai à
moins de 20 km de chez lui ou de chez
elle, il y aura un boulot correctement
payé et qu'on va lui demander quelles
sont ses compétences, quels sont ses
goûts et quelle est la formation. Et
donc est-ce qu'il veut aller travailler
dans le bâtiment ? Est-ce qu'il veut
travailler dans les énergies
renouvelables ? Est-ce qu'il veut
travailler dans les transports en commun
? Est-ce qu'il veut travailler dans on
va lui proposer et puis que globalement
quand l'ADEM dit qu'on peut créer 800000
ou 900000 emplois en France que si on
met en place ce traité, on va financer
la transition. et qu'on peut créer
800000 ou 900000 en tout chômage en
France c'est combien ?
Euh ben là il remonte depuis 4 mois.
J'ai vu hier on en parle pas beaucoup
mais les chiffres du chômage remonte et
alors euh
c'est combien de personnes ?
Euh ça dépend si on considère les
chômeurs de la catégorie A ou les
l'ensemble des chômeurs. On est à plus
de 6 millions. Ouais plus de 6 millions.
Plus de 6 millions. Et c'est intéressant
de voir comment même la BCE, la Banque
centrale européenne justement la BCE dit
"Comment se fait-il quand je mets 3000
milliards sur la table, ça aurait dû
booster l'économie et relancer les
salaires ?" On Voilà. Et la BCE dit il
me manque un problème, il y a un
engrenage qui ne marche plus parce que
dans mes théories il y a 40 ans, quand
met autant d'argent, ça relance
l'économie. Donc les salariés peuvent
demander une augmentation de salaire.
Donc la BCE a fait des études pour dire
qu'est-ce qui manque dans le et la BCE
arrive à dire que les chiffres du
chômage ne sont qu'une petite partie de
la réalité et que si on tient compte des
chômeurs mais aussi des chômeurs qui
sont découragés, ça fait 2 ans qu'ils
cherchent du boulot, ils sont plus
inscrits, ils sont tombés un c plus bas,
les effets de mange des politiques pour
masquer leur incompétence. tous les
petits les boulots à temps partiel qui
ne sont pas au chômage mais c'est juste
insupportable, on narrive pas à vivre
correctement avec ça. C'est la BCE qui
dit que en fait c'est 21 % des actifs
qui sont concernés par le chômage et la
une très grande précarité en Europe. 21
% 21 % ça représente combien ? Ben ça
représente sur euh là je sais plus mais
c'est ça veut dire que les chiffres
officiels qui sont à 8 ou 9 % ne sont
même pas la moitié du problème. Et ça
veut dire aussi qu'on est tous tirés
vers en bas que même quelqu'un ou
quelqu'une qui a un bon boulot dans une
entreprise quand tout le monde a la
trouille de de d'être un jour au chômage
la négociation sur les salaires, elle
est bloquée. Autrefois il y a 30 ans,
quand quelqu'un n'était pas content de
son boulot, il était crevé, il était
stressé, le patron était chiant ou il
avait fait le tour intellectuellement où
il était pas bien payé, il pouvait
donner sa démission et en 3 mois, il
retrouvait un boulot. Tàis que là quand
vous avez 20 % des gens qui sont en
situation de chômage ou de précarité,
tous ceux qui ont un boulot, ils se
disent "Ben c'est déjà mieux que rien."
6 millions de personnes, toi tu veux
créer 800000 emplois, c'est ça ? En
France ?
C'est pas que je veux, c'est que l'ADEM,
l'Agence pour les économies d'énergie
dit que si on a les financements qu'on
propose, il y aura des problèmes de
formation parce qu'aujourd'hui on aurait
pas les gens. Si demain on avait le les
45 milliards qu'on veut pour la France
chaque année, le le financement à taux
zéro, on a'urait pas les gens compétents
pour faire les diagnostic thermique,
pour faire les travaux d'isolation ou
pour implanter les énergies
renouvelables. Donc, mais c'est un
cercle vicieux. Si on n pas les
financements disponibles de façon
durable, les gens vont pas se mettre à
se former. Donc donc oui, on peut créer
800000 ou 900000 emplois rien qu'avec ce
levier, mais ça ne suffira pas si votre
prochaine question chiffre. Vas-y.
Et ben oui, ça ça je ne prétends pas
avec ce projet, nous ne prétendons pas
régler tous les problèmes. Loin de là.
Donc ton projet va faire perdre combien
de d'emploi ? Tu tu as chiffré ça ?
Les il y a des cré le bilan net quand on
a quand le chiffre de LAADEM c'est
800000 ou 900000, ça on tient compte des
destructions d'emploi. Donc
effectivement, il y aura moins de
chauffeurs routiers. C'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui on il y a des aliments qui
arrivent dans notre assiette qui ont
déjà fait 1000 ou 2000 km ou 3000 km. Si
on veut faire des circuits courts, si on
veut manger des choses où il y aura
moins de pesticides, moins de produits
chimiques et qui sont produits pour
l'essentiel à moins de 50 km ou moins de
100 km, il y aura beaucoup moins de
chauffeurs routiers. En Suisse, quand un
camion arrive, euh au lieu de lui faire
euh 200 km sur l'autoroute, on le met
sur un train et c'est très bien
organisé. Ça se fait en quelques
minutes, les chauffeurs ne perdent pas
de temps, mais il y a beaucoup moins de
chauffeurs routiers et plus de gens dans
le train.
Quand quand on voit la sur la production
de CO2 et tous les les gaz de de
polluant de moteur, on voit que les
constructeurs automobiles fraudent.
On voit que euh Volkswagen pour citer
que parce qu'on a peut-être fermé les
yeux sur les autres euh quand on voit
que le la réglementation n'est pas
appliquée pour les bateaux de croisière
que c'est pas appliqué pour les bateaux
qui transportent du fret,
c'est pas un petit peu déjà faire
appliquer la réglementation actuelle ?
C'est
évidemment évidemment
pourquoi on le fait pas ?
Mais je ne suis pas gouvernement. ça ne
vous a pas échappé que je ne suis pas
gouvernement et je n'ai jamais été
pe une petite interprétation quand même
parce que quand on voit un
il y a quelques lobby si vous voulez me
faire dire qu'il y a sans doute quelques
lobby qui mettent la petite ligne qui va
bien à 2h du matin à l'assemblée
non mais c'est c'est choquant on sait
très bien tous que si on va sur tel ou
tel site on peut trouver un billet
d'avion Paris Madrid ou Paris Barcelone
qui est moins cher c'est moins cher en
avion que qu'en train c'est juste
stupide c'est totalement choquant alors
qu'on veut sauver la planète que
quelqu'un qui crame du kérosel en
prenant son billet d'avion euh ça va lui
coûter moins cher que de prendre le TGV
ou le voilà. Donc parce que le kérosène
n'est pas assez taxé et parce que on
continue à trop privilégier ce genre de
d'énergie.
Sur la réglementation des polluants par
exemple sur les bateaux, comment ça se
fait que personne s'intéresse à ce
dossier là ?
Je trouve ça totalement anormal mais je
ne suis pas
Tu penses tu penses pouvoir te battre
contre des lobby hyper puissants, hyper
financés depuis des décennies bien bien
profondément. Je pense qu'il y a des
sujets qui tant qu'ils sont réservés à
on discute à trois ou quatre dans une
réunion ministérielle et les voilà
tandis que si on les met sur la table si
on les met si on fait un débat public il
y a des lobby qui parlent sur la
question de l'amiante. Si on avait pu à
mettre ça sur la dans l'espace public
plus tôt je pense qu'on aurait interdit
l'amiante beaucoup plus tôt. Donc notre
objectif c'est qu'un maximum de citoyens
comprennent qu'ils peuvent comprendre
ces questions, qu'ils peuvent comprendre
la gravité du problème climatique qu'ils
peuvent comprendre les questions
monétaires. On met des mots compliqués
pour leur faire peur le quantitative
easing. Tous les gens qui viennent à nos
conférences au quin du pays se disent
"Putain mais j'ai compris j'ai compris
ce que c'est la création monétaire et
comment on pourrait la mettre au service
des conférences environ 400 personnes à
chaque fois." C'est ça.
Oui. Puis puis ceux qui ceux qui
regardent par internet.
Non mais je dis pas qu'on va sauver le
monde tout seul. Donc on cherche des
alliés. Si je suis là aujourd'hui, si je
suis là aujourd'hui, non mais je le dis
sérieusement, c'est qu'on cherche des
alliés. On cherche à ce que ceux et
celles qui nous écoutent se disent
"Putain, il parle trop vite, je
comprends pas la moitié de ce qu'il
raconte mais globalement il va dans le
bon sens et il va pas y arriver tout
seul. Donc il faut qu'on l'aide." Tiens,
tu regardes la caméra là. Tu
je le redis tout à l'heure c'était pour
marteau. Mais elle est toujours là ou
pas ?
Ouais mais t'inquiète pas, on
l'appellera ce soir la tu leur dis on
est dans une merre de noir et ça va très
mal se terminer.
A priori c'est foutu mais on peut s'en
sortir. Voilà les deux messages que je
veux faire passer c'est a priori c'est
foutu. On a toutes les raisons de se
flinguer. Ça peut très très mal finir
mais on peut s'en sortir si on est des
millions à se dire pendant quelques mois
on y croit et on pousse ensemble dans le
même sens. Et que c'est au niveau
européen. Au niveau national il y a pas
les marges de manœuvre. au niveau
international avec Trump, c'est foutu et
par contre l'Europe a une responsabilité
et donc on peut faire du judo politique
et mettre la pression sur nos dirigeants
pour les pousser au courage.
Question d'Internet. Comment peut-il
parler de la question écologique sans
aborder la question sociale ?
C'est un reproche qu'on peut
difficilement me faire. Ça fait j'ai été
licencié de chez mon principal premier
employeur à cause de mes idées en
matière sociale et ça fait 25 ans que je
me bas sur les questions sociales, sur
la lutte contre la pauvreté et la
précarité.
Mais et donc là je j'y reviens par je
suis très heureux dans notre la campagne
qu'on a lancé pour tenir en traité sur
le climat, on a le président des
syndicats européens avec nous. On a la
fondation Abpiierre et l'équivalent de
la fondation Abpière dans plein de pays
d'Europe parce que tous ces gens-là se
battent sur les questions de justice
sociale et aujourd'hui sur les questions
de justice climatique.
Tu penses que les médias jouent jouent
correctement leur rôle dans le la
propagation de ces ces informations ou
de ces idées ou
il y a quand même une évolution depuis
quelques années quand on a la une du
monde les 15000 scientifiques qui tient
la sonnette d'alarme quand le hier
c'était le journalestrance qui m'a
invité à Renn et le journal Ouest France
nous a mis plusieurs fois la une. Je
crois aussi qu'il y a des journalistes
qui comme citoyens
commencent à se réveiller la nuit. Donc
euh oui, je trouve que
tu travailles la nuit, tu penses à quoi
?
Je vois maintenant franchement des
scènes d'horreur. Je pense vraiment
qu'on peut aller vers le chaos. C'est
récent depuis quelques semaines, mais
euh je pense que ça peut finir par des
guerres que ce qui se passe en Italie et
ailleurs m'inquiète vraiment. Je vois
des comportements totalement inhumains
qui sont assumés par les dirigeants
politiques qui ont pourtant un bon
niveau d'intelligence. Je pense qu' y
compris des gens comme Vquier en France
qui sont pourtant normal sub. Donc un
très bon niveau intellectuel et la la
République a payé des grandes études et
prêt à dire n'importe quoi pour jouer
sur les peurs. Et donc je c'est là
depuis quelques temps vraiment pourtant
je suis d'un naturel rigoluse. Les gens
qui me connaissent savent que je suis
plutôt un pas un anxieux mais je me dis
que ça fout du stress. Tu te réveilles,
c'estàd tu te réveilles d'un coup et tu
dis non mais non mais non, je vois des
scènes d'horreur que par l'autre jour,
j'ai vu comme les les gens les gens qui
qui fuyaient au Vietnam parce qu'ils
étaient bombardés et je pense que on
peut avoir des pays qui pètent les
plombs. L'histoire montre que des pays
peuvent péter les plombs. L'Allemagne
est un pays qui avait donné des grands
philosophes. La République de Vaemar
c'était une République. Et puis tout
d'un coup, il y a un moment où on pète
les plombs parce que ça fait trop
longtemps qu'il y a la précarité parce
que le système m'oppresse et pour
montrer que j'existe, j'ai besoin de
trouver un bouquet émissaire. Ben je
suis pas psychologue mais on a tous un
cerveau reptilien et pas seulement les
gens qui votent pour des parties
néonazasie et il y a un moment où
collectivement on peut péter les planss
et tu as pas l'impression que les États
s'organise pour ça en mettant de la
surveillance de masse en mettant de la
reconnaissance faciale un peu partout en
faisant de la big data sur ses
concitoyens pour faire de l'anticipation
prédictive.
J'ai pas beaucoup réfléchi à ces
questions. Pardon je prétends pas avoir
une vision universelle de toutes les les
sujets. Moi mon but c'est avec d'autres
et heureusement on est de plus en plus
nombreux. Je répète, il y a des l'autre
jour, on a fait un débat juieux, il y a
plusieurs dizaines d'étudiants qui ont
dit qu'il voulaient se former pour
devenir porte-parole et pour porter le
message à l'automne à des université
pour que ça qu'on foute le feu un peu
partout. J'ai pas beaucoup réfléchi à la
question de la surveillance que vous
posez. Je pense pas qu'on puisse dire
que les États s'organisent, pardon, pour
aller vers le chaos. Par contre, je
pense qu'il y a une inertie monstrueuse.
Je pense que nos dirigeants euh ne font
pas le job que aujourd'hui quand on lit
les rapports du GC, quand les rapports
du FMI, quand on voit le bilan
d'Eurostat qui dit que la France a
augmenté de 3 % ses émissions de gaz
effet de serre, on devrait le le
gouvernement devrait dire on prend une
semaine, on arrête les affaires
quotidiennes et on prend une semaine
pour voir en France ou en Europe comment
on change de modèle radicalement. Et ce
qui est incroyable, c'est de voir
comment moi j'étais dans chez Accenture,
mes premières années de pendant 11 ans,
j'ai bossé chez Accenture et ce qui
était à la mode, c'était le réingering,
c'était la disruption. Et encore
aujourd'hui, on dit que les entreprises
doivent se réinventer, faire la voilà et
que par contre en matière politique, on
ne met que des rustines. Ça fait 25 ans
que je participe au débat sur les
politiques sur l'emploi. On a fait aucun
progrès. Savoir le le lien entre le
progrès technologique, les gains de
productivité, est-ce que ça a un lien ou
pas avec le chômage ? On n pas fait
aucun progrès. Moi ça me terrifie de
voir comment il y a plein de domaines où
on fait des progrès en matière
technologique. On a tous des téléphones
qui sont maintenant des petits bijoux.
On imaginait pas il y a 25 ans qu'on
aurait ça. En matière médicale, j'ai une
copine qui est médecin qui me dit qu'on
a fait des progrès fabuleux pour lutter
contre certains cancers. Il y avait des
cancers de l'enfant qui étaient
quasiment toujours mortel il y a 30 ans
et maintenant on arrive quasiment à
sauver tous les enfants parce que les
médecins travaillent, les chercheurs
travaillent. Ils prennent un café le
matin quand ils arrivent et puis ils se
mettent au boulot et puis ils n'ont pas
le droit de mentir. Quelqu'un qui ment
dans un collue de médecine, il est foutu
dehors pour les 30 ans. Tandis qu'en
matière politique sur le climat
continuer de mentir. Le bilan est quand
même catastrophique. Le niveau de
chômage est monstrueux. Le niveau de
précarité.
Tu as été au Parti socialiste.
Oui, ça oui, personne n'est parfait mais
je l'ai quitté parce que je n'avais pas
réussi à le faire bouger. Mais voilà, je
dis pas que c'était un grand succès. Ma
mes deux passages au PS n'ont pas été
confiance dans Emmanuel Macron.
Je trouve que ce qu'on fait en ce moment
n'est pas la hauteur. Je le dis
franchement. Euh quand on voit le niveau
de chômage et de précarité, quand on
voit que depuis 4 mois le chômage
recommence à augmenter, quand on voit
inégalité
le les inégalités sont un niveau
monstrueux en France comme dans tous les
pays occidentaux, on continue à dire que
la croissance va revenir alors qu'on
sait c'est terrifiant. Le problème n'est
pas Emmanuel Macron plus que les autres,
c'est que tous les chefs d'état, on a
l'impression qu'ils ont une mémoire qui
dépasse pas 3 semaines. À chaque fois,
c'est pareil depuis 30 ans que moi que
je m'intéresse à la vie politique. À
chaque fois qu'on a la la que les
planètes sont alignées, voilà, quand le
pétrole est gratuit,
c'est quoi la CG ?
C'est l'alignement des planètes.
D'accord. Ben, j'ai appris un truc, j'ai
bien fait de venir. Donc, quand les
planètes, quand le pétrole est
Merci maître. Quand le pétrole est
gratuit, quand je le ferai dès que dès
que la caméra est éteinte, c'est promis.
Donc quand le pétrole est gratuit, les
taux d'intérêt sont fait, on peut
s'endetter. Donc à chaque fois, il y a
un peu plus de croissance. Quand c'était
Michel Rocard qui était à Matignon, il y
a 30 ans, on a eu 4 % 4 et5 de
croissance pendant 3 ans. Et puis ça
s'est planté et Rocard a dit "Je me suis
trompé, j'ai cru que la crise était
finie, c'était juste parce que le
pétrole était gratuit et les taux
d'intérêt." Puis après ça, de nouveau,
il y a eu un contre-choc quand Jospin
arrive. était pas la faute de Jospin,
c'est que le pétrole est gratuit, les
taux d'intérêt sont faibles, les
entreprises voilà, il y a eu 3 années de
croissance à 2 et demi. Donc ça durait
c'était j l'an dernier, le pétrole était
quasiment gratuit, les taux d'intérêt
étaient à zéro. On a eu une année où on
a eu une croissance à plus de 2 % et de
nouveau on a dit et là on l'INC nous dit
que ça retombe et quelle surprise alors
et quand on voit j'ai pas apporté tous
mes graphiques mais quand on voit quand
on voit l'évolution,
ça va faire mal
quand on voit l'évolution,
ça va faire mal. Donc je trouve que
c'est étonnant que des gens qui ont un
tel niveau de QI, ils sont tous bac + 8
hein. Les gens qui nous dérangent, qui
nous dirigent euh sont tous bac + 8.
Combien de cuits
de cuit ? J'en sais rien. Je ne j'ai
jamais mesuré, je m'en fiche. Mais je
trouve c'est tragique de voir que des
gens aussi intelligents sont capables de
reproduire les mêmes erreurs.
Intelligents ou fourbes ou est-ce qu'il
faut être intelligent pour être aussi
fourbe ?
Non non, je pense qu'ils sont
intelligents que les que les gens qui
nous dirigent dans la plupart des pays
occidentaux ont un niveau
d'intelligence. Voilà. Et je trouve
c'est que les le le niveau des
politiques est mise en place n'est pas
du tout à la hauteur. Ce que
c'est c'est de l'intelligence de savoir
sculter de la fumée, de brasser de l'air
chaud.
Pardon, j'ai pas
Est-ce que c'est une forme
d'intelligence de savoir sculter de la
fumée et brasser de l'air chaud ?
Je suis pas dans la posture du
commentateur. Moi, je suis vraiment
flippé. Je pense que ça peut très mal
finir. Je pense que la plupart des gens
qui nous dirigent sont habitués à des
des trucs qui sont qu'on peut modifier à
la marge et qui sont linéaires et ne
savent pas que des systèmes peuvent
s'effondrer. Moi, j'ai fait de la
biologie et je sais que des systèmes
peuvent s'effondrer. Je me souviens
quand ma mère était à l'hôpital et qu'un
médecin est sorti en larme de sa chambre
en disant que c'était fini, qu'il y en
avait plus que pour quelques semaines.
Donc je pense que un système humain, une
société peut s'écrouler, un l'Europe
peut s'écrouler, que la planète peut
s'effondrer, qu'on vit une petite
planète magnifique mais que en quelques
dizaines d'années, elle on peut aller
vraiment vers
si ça commence à partir si tu
m'autorises à parler trivialement, quand
ça va commencer à partir vraiment en
couille, est-ce que tu vas avoir une
bouteille de champagne que tu gardes
précieusement au frais, que tu vas
monter sur ton toit et que tu vas
regarder Babylone cramé,
qu'est-ce que tu comprendre Non non
parce que le le jour il y a quelques
années Lilian Turam qui m'a appelé pour
dire voilà on parle beaucoup de la crise
financière je pense à vous j'étais dans
les Pyrénées j'étais tout content je
fais j'écoute ça c'est l'antam qui
appelle parce qu'il m'avait dit qu'il
l'avait ditapp
je je on peut l'appeler mais et donc
j'étais fier je fais ça écoute à mes
enfants c'est Lilian Duram qui Non mais
c'est pas qui voilà on vous l'avait
annoncé voilà et j'en je suis heureux
pendant 10 minutes et je fais écouter ça
aux enfants mais sur le fond je me dis
tu n'es pas à la hauteur je ne
suis pas bon ok j'ai annoncé la crise
financière OK j'ai annoncé que la crise
n'était pas finie ok je sais que la
Chine, ça peut partir en vrai, avoir un
conflit avec le Japon et voilà. Et si je
n'arrive pas à si nous n'arrivons pas à
empêcher ça, c'est qu'on n'est pas bon.
Donc on peut dire que Macron n'est pas
la hauteur. On peut dire que Merkel
n'est pas la hauteur mais nous est-ce
qu'on se donne les moyens ? On a
internet, on a tous interément
optimiste.
Non, je suis pas optimiste. Je te dis
que je vous dis que ça peut a priori
qu'est-ce que toi tu as regarde,
imagine-toi si ça faisait 10 ans allez
si ça faisait 12 ans que tu étais
réveillé la nuit par la passivité
intellectuelle des gens.
ce misérabilisme de l'impuissance et si
tu av cognitive de pouvoir faire
accélérer l'horloge et de voir à peu
près comment ça allait partir en
déliquence, imagine-toi, tu aurais
peut-être un plan B, genre bah un plan
du genre bon cette cette meute ou ce
troupeau de connard incapable de se
bouger pour des questions vitales,
tu vas peut-être pas te limiter. Tuas tu
as préparé un petit plaisir quand même.
Je sais pas, tu as un petit cigare ou tu
vas les regarder ou tu vas continuer à
pédaler et à brasser de l'air avec tes
tes bras jusqu'au dernier moment.
Si en 2020 ton traité il passe pas, on
en 2021 tu viens à la maison, on se boit
une coupe de champagne.
OK. Ça de toute façon, j'ai pas refusé.
Vous avez l'air sympa, mais a priori
plutôt là pour je suis sur l'idée qu' ça
peut qu'on peut gagner. Il peut-être une
chance sur 10, mais ça peut gagner.
Voilà. Euh un match.
D'accord. Si ça gagne pas, qu'est-ce que
tu
Ça gagne pas ? On verra. Mais si ça
gagne pas.
Mais le problème c'est que les
progressif tu un peu comme un politique
qui me dit on va gagner les élections
présidentielles c'est comme Nicolas
Dupontan qu'on a reçu. Merci pour la
comparaison. Bon je m'en vais je dois
partir qui m'attend
la comparaison avec du Pignan jusque là
tout s'était bien passé mais la
si tu veux un autre si tu veux un autre
on d'autre
non mais pardon est-ce qu'on se
dit qu'on peut peut-être gagner qu'on
peut peut-être mais que c'est pas qui a
encore un énorme boulot à faire. Donc
avant de réfléchir au plan B et au plan
Z prime, est-ce qu'on peut déjà
réfléchir comment on a une chance pas
inclure dans ton prisme de lecture que
tu peux perdre ?
Ah mais j'y pense régulièrement quand je
dis qu'il y a une chance sur 10. Je suis
pas une bête en math mais ça veut dire
qu'il y a une chance sur 10 qu'on gagne.
Ça veut dire qu'il y a 9 chances sur 10.
Tu veux pas tu veux donc si tu perds tu
fais quoi ? Mais je sais pas, on verra
après. Pardon, j'ai j'ai pas réfléchi,
excuse-moi, mais vous vraiment désolé,
j'ai pas réfléchi. Là, on bosse 6 jours
par semaine et encore le dimanche à des
réunions et on est en train de se former
pour qu'il y ait plus de porte-parolees.
On prépare un petit bouquin. Tu souviens
le petit bouquin de Stéphane Nessel,
indignez-vous. Donc, l'éditrice de
Stéphane Essel nous a demandé, Stéphane
n'est plus là, mais la fille de Stéphane
Anessel est avec nous. Donc, on est en
train de préparer un petit bouquin pour
le début du mois d'octobre. En même
temps, on veut lancer le débat à
Amsterdam. En même temps, comme c'est
des on a des alliés à Madrid, il faut y
aller. En même temps, à Rome. Voilà. On
est on est pour le moment peut-être que
c'est basique mais on est sur l'idée que
quand il y a un match à jouer, quand on
est moi je fais du basket dans ma
jeunesse, ben pour le moment on se
concentre sur le match jusqu'au bout, on
joue le match et voilà
c'est tout à ton honneur.
Non mais c'est peut-être voilà et pour
le moment par manque de temps, on n' pas
réfléchi à la suite
question d'internet. Est-ce qu'on peut
continuer à donner des emplois
d'esclaves aux gens en leur enlevant
leurs cadeaux, leurs jouets, voiture,
voyage ?
Mais mon but c'est pas que les gens
aient des boulots d'esclaves quand je me
bats cette année je n'en parle pas quand
je suis en France la question du temps
de travail la semaine de 4 jours parce
que je voilà je préfère réunir en même
temps Laurence Pariso et les syndicats
en même temps Alternativa et Jean-Pierre
Afarin pour gagner la bataille du climat
mais la semaine dernière j'étais à
Bruxelles, on m'a demandé de venir faire
un grand débat sur la question du temps
de travail et bien quand une entreprise
se passe à 4 jours, ça enrichit le
travail parce que par quand vous allez
chez Maminova, le directeur de l'usine
est passé à 4 jours. Donc il y a des
choses qui donnent à son numéro 2.
numéro 2 passe à 4 jours et et là on
embauche quelqu'un et y compris jusqu'à
l'ouvrier le les gens au premier niveau
qu'il y a un jour par semaine où le
contemettre n'est pas là mais si un
client appelle on peut pas dire rappelez
lundi parce que le contemître est en
vacances donc on a enrichi le travail le
fait de passer à 4 jours, ça a créé
massivement des emplois ils ont embauché
120 personnes. Donc il y a eu un effet
de masse, on a embauché 120 personnes en
CDI et pour la plupart des salariés, ça
a été un enrichissement du travail. Donc
on voit du coup que l'absentéisme
diminue parce que les gens s'ennuient
moins. Donc mon but n'est pas enfin
notre but, je pense qu'on est euh cinq
dans la pièce, notre but n'est pas que
les les gens aient un boulot d'esclaves.
On est huit. Euh
pardon, il y a des gens qui sont tout
petit qui ont qui se sont cachés.
Quelle porte reste à ouvrir pour que ça
bouge ? Qu'est-ce qui coince encore pour
le moment ?
Je pense qu'on n'est pas assez nombreux
à comprendre la gravité du problème et
en même temps à se dire que c'est pas
foutu. Voilà, il faut faire grandir
l'intersection. Il y a des gens qui
n'ont pas encore compris la gravité du
problème et puis parmi ceux qui ont
compris la gravité, il y en a qui se
résignent en pensant que c'est foutu,
qu'on y arrivera pas. Donc l'enjeu c'est
de mettre les gens en mouvement. Partout
où je vais, j'explique, je suis pas là
pour faire une conférence mais pour
trouver des alliés quels que soient les
gens qui m'invitent. Voilà. Et si on est
capable de se dire au moins, est-ce
qu'on peut y croire que on se donne 6
mois ou un an pour gagner la bataille ?
Et si on est des millions à y croire, ça
peut le faire.
Notredame des pour toi,
mais c'est une première victoire. C'est
la preuve qu'on peut faire bouger les
choses pour plein de raisons.
Ils sont fait défoncer quand même.
Mais ils sont fait défoncer globalement
quand même. Cet aéroport ne va pas se
faire. Quand je dis que c'est une
victoire, c'est que cet aéroport ne va
pas se faire. Après ça, il y a eu
beaucoup de violence. Moi, je
Est-ce qu'il faut des zones
d'expérimentation ?
Oui, je pense que le le terr arabes
Notre Dame des Landes devrait pour
servir pour des des zones
d'expérimentation sur d'autres pratiques
agricoles. Ça me paraît et donc oui, il
y a eu de la violence. Moi, je d'une
manife il y a quelques années, je suis
j'ai oublié la date, mais on était
plusieurs milliers. C'était une manif
tout à fait bon enfant. Il y avait des
gens toutes les générations, il
faisaient beau. Les sondages
expliquaient que 80 % des gens ne
voulaient pas du deuxème aéroport et on
s'est pris des lacrymogènes et
visiblement les CRS avaient des
consignes pour ne pas choper les il y
avait quelques casseurs qu'on a laissé
faire. C'était tout à fait clair qu'on a
laissé faire.
C'est peut-être des flics.
Non, je pense je suis pas dans pas là
mais par contre je pense effectivement
Manuel Vals ou d'autres avait envie
d'instrumentaliser la violence et que du
coup le journal de 20h commençait juste
par des violences à Nantes alors que
c'était une manife totalement pacifique.
Voilà. De même à Syvin quand moi j'ai
quitté la manife de Syvin, c'était une
manife qui avait été totalement
pacifique. Les dernières images, c'était
ma voisine qui donnait le sein à son
bébé. Il y en a qui jouait de la
musique. C'était cool de chez cool. Et
quand on s'est séparé, tout le quelques
députés qui étaient là disaient "En plus
lundi, on aura un rapport, c'est Golen
Royal va dire qu'on abandonne le
projet." Donc c'est un vrai sujet. C'est
aussi la réflexion de John Palé des de
c'est comment éviter la violence et
comment euh faire gagner nos causes par
des mouvements non violents.
Que pensent-il de la collapsologie ?
Euh la collapsologie, c'est les gens qui
disent que ça peut s'effondrer. Rie
déduction.
Oui, ben je pense qu'ils ont raison. Ça
peut s'effondrer. Ça peut s'effondrer.
Les systèmes, je sais plus, c'est Ken
Rogov qui disait ça ou je sais plus qui
qui disait que les systèmes tiennent
souvent plus longtemps qu'on le pense,
mais ils s'effondrent plus vite qu'on
l'imagine. Voilà. Et c'est il le disait
pour c'est l'ancien numéro 2 du de la
Banque mondiale qui disait ça et il
disait ça pour le système financier. On
met des rustines pour le moment il tient
mais s'il s'effondre il peut s'effondrer
plus vite. Mais c'est vrai aussi pour un
système biologique. Un corps humain peut
en quelques semaines ou en quelques
heures mourir. Et c'est vrai pour un
corps social. C'est vrai pour une
société où tout d'un coup on peut une
société peut s'effondrer. Il a on le on
le voit dans l'histoire. Il y a aucun
doute. Un peuple peut péter les plombs.
Je le répète, le peuple allemand était
un peuple qui avait donné des grands
philosophes, des grands musiciens, qui
avaient fait la République de Vaimar. Et
tout d'un coup, parce qu'il y a une
flambée du chômage et de la précarité,
ça fait le le cerveau reptilien domine
et donc je pense que oui, on peut avoir
un effondrement et qu'on accumule tout
ce qu'on laisse pourrir depuis 30 ans en
disant bon après tout, ça peut encore
tenir quelques années, il y a un moment
où ça peut faire système et faire mal.
Allez, pour quand ta prochaine grève de
la fin ?
Je ne sais pas.
Tu t'y prépares ? Si c'est pour dire que
j'ai 3 kg en trop la le fait que j'ai 3
kg en trop. Oui, c'est bon. Mais non,
j'espère qu'on peut gagner autrement
mais je n'en sais rien encore ce matin à
Ber quelqu'un me disait mais au
fonctionnaires en même temps disait
comment est-ce qu'on peut vous aider sur
les aspects budgétaires ? Et il m'a déjà
envoyé un texto pour qu'on se revoit sur
concrètement au niveau je veux pas
donner de son nom. Euh et en même temps
il disait devant ses collègues quand
est-ce qu'on va dans la rue ? Et je
pense qu'il faut pas laisser la rue au
néonazie ceux qui veulent les
réfugiés. Je pense qu'à un moment, il
faudrait peut-être s'exprimer de façon
non violente pour dire que ce qui se
passe est extrêmement grave. Oui.
Quelle forme ça prendrait ?
Je ne sais pas. Je ne sais pas mais je
suis preneur qu'on y réfléchisse. On est
d'abord focalisé vraiment le jour on a
fait une réunion un autre QG avec plein
d'associations, des différents réseaux
qui veulent s'associer pour gagner la
bataille à l'automne. L'automne va être
très important. Il va y avoir le rapport
du GC, le rapport de l'ONU, la COP 24 et
le sommet des chefs d'état. Donc il faut
vraiment qu'on soit capable d'avoir une
vraie stratégie et d'être vraiment
efficace, de passer en mode efficacité
totale pour l'automne. Et si on arrive
pas à convaincre nos dirigeants,
peut-être qu'il faudra être de façon non
violente dans la rue pour dire que ce
qui se passe est grave et qu'on ne peut
pas se résigner.
Alors question internet. Pourquoi les
écolos sont moqués ne sont pas pris au
sérieux ? À cause d'une mauvaise
politique écolo ? À cause d'un effet de
lobbing
de d'une industrie qui les fait passer
pour des demeurer ?
Je sais pas.
Je sais pas moi, j'étais pendant un
moment Europe écologie, il y avait des
gens très bien et puis il y avait des
gens beaucoup moins bien et on voit que
on dit souvent que le poisson pourrit
par la tête et à Europe écologie, il
suffisait de deux ou trois personnes qui
en fait n'en avait rien à de la
jolie est pourrie.
Ah non, pas du tout. Je pensais plutôt
s'en placer mais Oh non, ça m'a échappé.
Pardon, pas de nom. Euh voilà. Donc non,
mais voilà. Donc il y a des gens qui
n'en avaient pas grandchose à faire, ni
du climat, ni de l'éthique. On mettait
Evoli devant qui est vraiment une femme
de conviction et puis derrière il y en a
qui avaient une éthique personnel très
différente et qui du coup n'ont pas été
sans doute capable d'imposer des idées
dans le débat public. Parce que quand on
a plusieurs ministres et qu'on a un
groupe de députés, on a des moyens
politiques, humains, financiers. On
pourrait mettre des idées sur le dans le
débat.
Bon, on arrive à la fin de notre
interview.
Elle se fin toujours de la même manière,
c'est-à-dire laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations, quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur les
réseaux.
On t'écoute.
Cinq conseils.
Laiss alors avant, on va on va te
laisser te préparer. Donne-nous cinq
bouquins à lire.
Ouf, là je suis trop fatigué pour faire
ce choix. Non mais
tr tris
je ne sais pas. Ne pas se décourager. Ne
pas se décourager. Garder dans sa vie.
Non non non non. Concentre-toi là. On
veut trois livres. Donne-nous trois
livres.
Je ne sais pas, j'ai pas envie de partir
sur des livres techno. J'ai pas envie
non plus. Tu
dis quoi en ce moment ?
Pas grand-chose en ce moment. Hélas,
j'attends.
Dernier bouquin que tu lu, c'est quoi ?
Euh,
je ne sais pas. Je suis vraiment
fatigué. Je lis des bouquins où ma femme
de donne des morceaux à lire.
Mon livre préféré,
c'était il y a très longtemps.
Ah bah, vas-y, hein.
C'est un livre qui s'appelait Pleur au
mon pays bien-aimé. Euh c'était il y a
très très longtemps mais et puis je lis
des bouquins sur euh Mandela, sur Martin
Luther King, sur des mais euh je lis
peu, je lis par manque ben je lis
beaucoup de rapports pour être en terme
de crédibilité mais je n'ai pas beaucoup
de temps. J'essaie de garder du temps
pour ma vie perso. J'ai une femme et des
enfants, j'essaie de garder du temps
pour ça et puis le le militantisme
m'occupe pas mal. Donc du coup
bon allez,
je ne vais pas très souvent au théâtre,
je ne vais pas assez souvent au cinéma.
Voilà. Conseil pour les jeunes
générations,
ben continuer à vivre joyeusement tout
en dans sa vie perso, tout en ayant
conscience de la gravité de la situation
et donc s'engager. Ne de ne pas ne pas
se laisser abîmer, ne pas se laisser
noircir par la gravité de la situation.
Voilà, dans sa vie personnelle,
continuer à vivre tout ce qu'il y a de
génial. Et puis par contre ne pas
refuser l'obstacle, ne pas nier la ne
pas nier la gravité de ce qui se passe
autour de nous et donc s'engager avec
d'autres pour faire bouger les choses.
Et on peut prendre son pied en
s'engageant. Euh c'est de façon moins
vulgaire, c'est Senine Kirkegard, le
philosophe Kirkegard qui disait "Une
mauvaise conscience peut rendre la vie
intéressante et je crois qu'au lieu de
nier les problèmes, on peut se dire
"C'est pas de ma faute, c'est pas un
problème de mauvaise conscience perso."
Tu es en train d'absoudre ton âme là ?
Non, je mon âme va très bien. N' pas
besoin d'être absu de quoi que ce soit.
Non non, mais c'est juste que je pense
qu'il faut vraiment conscience.
Non, j'ai pas du tout mauvaise
conscience. Je me sens absolument pas
responsable. Nous sommes collectivement
responsables nos nos parents, nos
grands-parents et ils ne savaient
peut-être pas ce qu'il faisait. Donc je
mon problème n'est pas du tout c'est
pour ça que l'expression de Kirard le
début c'est pas une mauvaise conscience.
Moi, je n'ai pas eu tout mauvaise
conscience, mais l'idée que ça peut
rendre la vie intéressante, qu'il y a
plein de gens qui s'ennuient euh ou qui
se vident la tête à regarder des
conneries tellement leur vie est
ennuyeuse et que le fait de prendre à
bras le corps les problèmes, la question
du climat, la question de la diversité,
la question de la justice sociale, la
question du dialogue nord- sud, le fait
de se dire "Putain, ça peut rendre la
vie intéressante, on rencontre des gens
intéressants, on se sent vivant, on voit
aussi nos faiblesses que tout seul on
n'y arrive pas mais le fait d'agir avec
d'autres pour changer le monde peut
rendre la vie intéressante et encore
plus joyeuse."
Pierre Larou. Merci.
Merci.
[Musique]